tomorrow is the last day that you can
vote in the California recall election
to remove Gavin Newsom and maybe get
someone else maybe it's Larry Elder
maybe it's one of these other Democrats
that are running and there are many
there's a couple stories that are
popping up and some statements from
former president Trump that are causing
alarm in one story from KTLA people are
saying that they went to go vote but
we're told they already voted and would
have to cast provisional ballots while
they're pretty upset about this another
video is going viral where someone's
filming as they're being told I'm sorry
it says you already voted and people are
getting very upset about this well it
doesn't help then when Donald Trump
comes out and says the whole thing's
rigged and I'll tell you why it's
demoralizing and it's not demoralizing
the left They're laughing they're
calling Republicans and people on the
right stupid they're saying that they're
dumb in there and they're suppressing
their own votes and you know what this
kind of rhetoric demoral is people so
I'll say I'll say right off the bat you
got it you gotta take this stuff you got
to push it off to the side don't ignore
it completely you know we should figure
out why these mistakes or whatever
happened happened maybe there's some
malintent we don't know but at the very
least do not let it demoralize you and
make sure whatever you believe and
whatever you want to do you go out and
you vote you tell your friends to do it
you go talk to friends family knock on
doors and don't let the news stop you
from engaging in your Civic duties
so we're going to talk about all this
stuff boy do we got a lot of news
apparently there the US government's not
going to give like something was like 64
million dollars to Afghanistan the
Taliban and that'll be really I don't
know awful so look into that we are
being joined today by Dan Holloway of
drinking Bros nice to be here yeah you
want to just introduce yourself real
quick yeah I'm Dan Holloway of drinking
Bros
I knew that I knew you were trying to
stall so I was trying to
install it just give you the business uh
no it's good to be here I agree with you
though if if voting is is that important
to get that upset about and I I think
the presumption is that that's correct
right we all think the Voting is
important absolutely and it's important
to continue to push through regardless
of what you think may be happening you
know what I mean there's nothing you can
do about it now the courts may be able
to decide something like that later I
mean who knows right like you said it
could be the errors happen all the time
let's imagine it's just one error and
one small precinct for five people and
that could demoralize how many thousands
of people so don't let that stuff
demoralize you man we were talking about
it before the show uh the some of the
rhetoric from the last campaign probably
had not probably it certainly had a a
huge effect on voter turnout right you
would think in Georgia they think oh
yeah but we'll we'll get into all this
stuff I think you know I think we're we
agree on that stuff we gotta eat and
chilling oh thank you very much Tim
happy to be here Dan great to see you
man yeah good to be here I am also in
the corner pushing the buttons I'm back
from my vacation getting my sister
married in Chicago and I did not get
shot so I was very pleased with that I'm
happy the part of Chicago though right
it was in a nice part of Chicago not
Chicago proper yeah depending on where
you are there's uh there's pockets are
you a Cubs fan or a White Sox fan I
guess you could say right I don't know
Cubbies am I going to get hurt for
saying that out loud on the North side
for a few years so it's hard not to love
the Cubs
I was in socks town but me and my
friends we didn't really care all that
much right you know hey let's uh before
we get started we got a sponsor today we
got uh the best sponsor we got virtual
Shield VPN virtual private network
service go to
surfinginternetsafe.com and you can get
50 off of your VPN service for life
they say every you can enjoy 24 months
of online security from the world's
easiest and fastest VPN for only 59.88
cents that's actually over 77 off plus
you'll get 50 off all add-ons and other
great discounts on their other plans
they're also proud to announce that this
month all discounts are guaranteed for
life that means 50 off for as long as
you're a customer again surfing internet
safe now if you're not familiar with a
VPN service it's basically a simple
layer of security for you as you're
browsing the web to make it harder for
hackers and spies governments and
corporations to track your data and it
really really does help if you ever use
one of those like if you've used like
the brave browser for instance it shows
you all of the crazy things that are
tracking you so you know look close your
blinds right if you want the world to be
a look in your living room see what
you're doing okay fine maybe you don't
want blunts maybe you're into that kind
of thing and if you're not then you know
you want to get a VPN service and surf
the Internet safe by going to
surfinginternetsafe.com and I will also
mention virtual Shield is my first
sponsor we've ever had for any of the
podcasts I've done any of the shows
they've been with us through thick and
thin they're they are awesome great
respect and eternal thank you again go
to surfinginternetsafe.com check them
out support those who support us and
don't forget go to timcast.com become a
member because we're going to have that
members only segment coming up after the
show and you'll not want to miss it we
always swear we swear a lot we say
naughty words you know because YouTube's
mean to us but this is where we can have
a lot of those conversations that
typically in the news cycle it's harder
to get through so again go there you'll
be you'll be supporting our journalists
and become a member as well and don't
forget to like this video subscribe to
this channel share the show with your
friends let's get to this uh first story
here from KTLA we got to break this one
down this is this is a worrying story
they say
San Fernando Valley residents cast
provisional ballots due to equipment
issue they say some San Fernando Valley
voters think they are being wrongly
prevented from casting a ballot in the
upcoming gubernatorial recall election
but the County elections office said it
was an equipment issue that was resolved
okay so there's good news right at El
Camino Real Charter High School in
Woodland Hills some voters say they were
told the computers showed them as
already having voted even though they
had not West Hills resident Estelle
Bender 88 said she was far from the only
person who was being told incorrectly
that they had already voted now for
those that aren't familiar with what's
going on this is the recall election
Governor Gavin Newsom could be removed
and that means whoever is is on on the
list who gets the most votes no matter
how many could become the new governor
of California for the next year or so
right now it's looking like that would
be Larry Elder the polls that have come
out lately show that you know Gavin
Newsom is doing really really well and
he's 16 points up in the 538 aggregate
but let me just tell you uh the polling
was extremely wrong in basically like
the past several elections going best
fought going back five or so years so I
wouldn't rely on that and more
importantly when you see stories like
this and there are many check out this
one we got this one uh actually this is
not that's not the story I was looking
for here's the ones from Dave Rubin he
says holy-ish listen to this as an at an
LA voting voting Center voter quote
about 70 percent of votes this location
have been already shown as cast but they
are not election official right right
this is someone questioning supervisor
Vincent McCormick these are from this is
a verified twitteries are posting this
video so people are looking at this
stuff they're thinking something you
know bad is happening I'll say this and
then we'll jump into that conversation
don't let it demoralize you for for real
right now I see a lot of people saying
things they're sharing these stories
saying like what's the point oh like
there's a point it's go out and vote
because this is a story about a handful
of people and for all you know it was a
glitch that's all it was and they fixed
it and how many people now are like I
give up what's the point that's the
problem you've got to hold the line it's
like that movie I mentioned this earlier
the movie with Mel Gibbs and the Patriot
when when the British are charging in
and then the militia starts breaking
it's like no and he grabs the flag and
he runs back towards him and he says
hold the line and they do and they win
that you got to do yeah otherwise Gavin
Newsom wins right right you don't want
that I mean who who needs several more
years of that hair you know what I mean
well he'll get one more year I suppose
but right yeah but then what does even
if there is a recall we'll see I mean I
guess if there's if anything uh you
would expect that this has ruined him
for the national stage because it seems
like he was being primed for it but I
would have said the same thing about uh
Kamala Harris and her record on on well
everything right like it's yeah she's
awful it's very bizarre how most of the
female candidates at the federal level
that the Democrats seem to push are com
have records at a completely
antithetical to their causes at the time
like think about Hillary Clinton at the
time
uh the priorities for the Democrats were
getting out of Iraq you know uh uh uh
women first all this stuff uh marriage
equality she was against marriage
equality until 2013 when she got forced
into being for it uh she voted for
everything Iraq the Patriot Act the
agree the new Iraq everything voted for
all that and she spent the late 90s
going after the personal lives of all
the women her husband allegedly sexually
assaulted right so she checked all the
boxes on the other side she couldn't
have been a worse candidate and then
remember the narrative from that
election she's the most she's single
most qualified candidate in U.S history
for president I believe is what was said
are you kidding me like she doesn't
believe any of the things that you
believe and you're putting her forward
that's I mean it just shows you how
completely morally bankrupt all this
stuff really is
YouTube's giving us the business yeah it
is trying to fix it yeah you to be yeah
I thought uh Eisenhower was was the best
one of the best presidents anyway about
him yeah he was a military commander so
he knew what he was doing with worried
an interstate highway system he built
the interstate yeah the GI Bill the VA
home loan that built the middle class in
the United States he's responsible for a
lot of stuff right I like that good
president yep uh this Gavin Newsom guy
is a little a little awkward the gel in
his hair he's like he's he's a
caricature of all the things people hate
about politicians like if you're trying
to sneak in and be the new guy on the
Block and like you know uh be a
professional politician you at least
have to if you're a wolf you better put
the Sheep's clothes on if you show up
dressed like a wolf he's like oh this
guy's a he's a wolf yeah but it's
working for him that's the shocking yeah
you know Gavin Newsom looks like
there's a movie where there's a villain
a politician who's the villain yeah but
he's not like the the main bad guy he's
like you know the the secret
supervillain has bought a politician and
Gavin Newsom would play the generic
politician sellout corporate you know
corrupt criminal that's what he looks
like yeah but that's that's kind of you
know look you see the problems
California's facing and you have to
wonder what it is the guy does I know
that he puts in absurd cover
restrictions and then violates them and
uh I know the state has been in you know
shambles for some time now and he's not
doing anything about it he's been really
supportive of the movement towards
lawlessness there as well I mean uh we
were talking about it earlier about how
Soros has been financially invested in
all these attorney general and judge
races across the country over the past
six years or so and all of a sudden he
just dumps a million dollars in there
and newsom's recall campaign that's kind
of bizarre right did he I mean then you
have a gascon in the in the D.A in La
that are there I think they're going to
start paying people to not shoot other
people right you guys are yeah that was
that in L.A no that was in San Fran
wasn't it is that Portland OR San
Francisco or someone else it's in
California it is in California
yeah they decided you know what how
about we but the funny thing is like how
do you pay someone not to shoot someone
how do you hate me I didn't do it
what their plan is they're they're going
to uh identify people who are likely to
like commit crimes or whatever so what
does that mean they're going to go
somebody be like we've determined that
you are probably a low life degenerate
who would shoot someone so we're gonna
give you money right now and hope you
don't like how do you feel about that as
a criminal are you like all right cool
I'm going to play the grift and get the
money but it's they were talking about
300 bucks that's a couple of
transactions if you're a drug dealer
right that's nothing I mean that's and
they said if you get a job too it's 500
bucks like don't shoot someone you'll
get 500 this is real I guess yes I got a
job and didn't shoot someone and all I
got was this five hundred dollars I know
right I don't know it seems a little
ridiculous the heck that's that's very
bizarre San Francisco yeah San Francisco
yeah so we're also paying people 85
Grand a year to pick up human excrement
off the ground so you know what's really
funny here's the way I describe it to
people I'm like so you live in a city
right you know where you live in a city
sure sir yes you have a fire department
yeah uh yep you have a police department
yep you have a EMS yep do you have a
poop Department
I mean there's a department of
sanitation I think that no processes
San Francisco literally has poop poop
yeah I mean what are the uniforms recall
this guy I mean come on
no way I gotta say I don't I don't know
if I can blame the governor I don't know
if I can blame the leaders of of
overseeing the ship as it's sinking
because we've been on this course since
1913. if not before that but it's it
we're basically built a Ponzi scheme and
now we're seeing it shatter and I don't
care who was in charge of that if
they're going to try and pilot that it's
going to shatter and so it's like no
reason to Pariah these dudes why 1913
Federal Reserve was formed right but you
I mean you think that you really think
that was the end and tell me what
coercion of the American government
I agree with him by the fascists yeah
yeah like have you ever seen we were
talking about it earlier uh have you
ever seen that uh Canadian sci-fi series
uh Continuum if you should watch it
basically they have like a corporate
Congress
so yeah yeah and it's set in like the
late or I'm sorry it's set in like the
early 21st century in Seattle I believe
but they're all Canadians and
uh corporations
fund the government more or less and so
they have a a say in what what happens
and what doesn't happen right and
obviously in the future it's a dystopian
nightmare but I I feel like right now
the ability of
anyone regardless if it's a corporate
interest to the government to control
what information is and isn't available
right especially these days when it's so
easy to spend a piece of information
that is more powerful than any weapon
you could ever dream of right fourth and
fifth generational Warfare yeah you know
what it's been going through my head
recently is should I respond to that guy
is someone I like or someone says
something I'm like if I make a response
to them am I gonna get flagged and put
on a list that's
I mean so far I just said aft I didn't
say the word that I normally say out
loud I am censoring myself at a level
I've never done before well maybe not
never maybe not never because I was in
the entertainment industry right and I
want to say you can't go on like Tucker
Carlson's show and say a lot you can say
more on this one than you can say what's
disturbing me is just I'm just not
responding to certain people because I'm
afraid it's going to put me on a list is
that crazy are you crazy come on I just
didn't hear on Tim cast IRL I mean I
guess that's one way to think just
assume I'm already on the list and just
talk to anyone I want to talk to but
like the way they're tracking social
media and like persecuting people that
were near the the capital on January
from their jobs yeah that's weird that
whole I mean I'm sure you guys have
talked exhaustively about the capital
thing but I always wondered and I'm
curious what your audience thinks about
this idea so the United States has what
like on record about 400 million guns
some more guns than people and so it's
the most armed population on Earth and
then the most armed subsection of that
population the what they consider to be
the far right shows up to overthrow the
government and they left all their guns
at home yeah that seems plausible right
respecting the law respecting the local
laws
I believe that there are people that
exist that are crazy that happen to be
conservative and they're going to do
dumb stuff sometimes and they'll say
they're doing it on behalf it could sort
of the same way people do uh from the
left from religion from everywhere right
always that there's always that will
always exist and I'll believe it exists
if you provide me evidence to that
effect in a certain circumstance but
when you tell me that three or four
hundred people show up out of a mass of
like 1.3 million people and and they
just all they showed up to overthrow the
government and forgot all their weapons
I don't believe you the FBI is America
the FBI said it that's not that's not
true there was no coordinator they were
mad because the way the election they
thought the election was going with the
voting so they wanted to show Power they
wanted to feel it like they had some
sort of power and why don't you put in a
four-year file a foia request for your
name
and see what comes up I thought about it
but it's like just do I want to dig up
that Wormhole man I'm gonna shut down I
would like I guess I could see it I
don't want to make myself more paranoid
than I need to quote you a bunch of
times on this show probably yeah I bet
mine's massive you know everyone here
I'm sure a lot of people who watch
actually might have something well yes
the splc is weighed in on you a number
of times right there was like two two
things and one it got retracted with an
apology because they they claimed that
uh
a holocaust denying Archive of a website
that I had gone to Iran for a holocaust
design conference which is like one of
the most insane crackpot things you can
ever publish and so they were forced to
take that down issue or attraction and
apology because I've never been to Iran
that's just Plum nuts well Bill Maher uh
and uh religious have you seen that
looks like a documentary religious
religious yeah yeah so he he went to
this uh area and visited with a Jewish
rabbi who was a holocaust denier so is
he on a list is Bill Martin a list for
interviewing people he finds it yeah but
even if you went to something like that
to cover it that doesn't that is what
journalism is supposed to be right well
no this website claimed I was like a
speaker oh boy and it's just like it's
just crackpot nonsense it's like dude if
some weirdo puts my name on a website
you believe it's true that so they had
to take it down and apologize the splc
is is immaterial it's it's oh yeah yeah
they're not the people who spend their
time worried look I get a lot of smear
pieces written about me all the time and
you know the most annoying thing in the
world is is when someone sends me it and
I'm like first of all you think I don't
know second of all why should I read it
or care like literally it's not
affecting me in any way it's there's
there's zero impact on my business it's
just a waste of time from from from
whiny you know stupid babies who I don't
care about it is uh your time is
certainly better spent doing other
things and the people it's a distraction
they try they try and wrap you up and
catch up on the stuff and and you know
what uh um to segue right back in what
we're talking about it's demoralizing it
is yeah if you spend all your day
looking at the people saying mean things
about you it's distracting you from
doing good work they're they're snaring
you in that trap ignore it I would say
getting involved in these uh in the
weeds conversations about what is and
isn't we were talking about this earlier
uh people are are
people are spending a lot of time
debating what communism and socialism
and fascism is why don't we just call it
what it is it's authoritarianism it
doesn't matter where it comes from if
your house is on fire you're not sitting
there like I wonder how my house caught
on fire no you're grabbing buckets of
water and trying to put the fire right
in you know and it's it's going to take
a collective effort to do that and I
don't I understand that tempers run hot
and all this stuff and people are afraid
I wanna let's talk about this story in
California we'll talk about why uh
people are upset so this was something I
saw retweeted and it's this guy telling
a story I don't know if this story is is
true or not it's just Twitter but uh but
let's check it out because I I think
it's interesting he says last week later
on the day literally on the day my new
wife and I came home to SF after our
wedding an intoxicated man confronted us
on our doorstep blocked the way out of
our home and threatened to stab me
unfortunately this isn't an unusual
occurrence in our city and my experience
is no more special than anyone else's so
this isn't the thread about the incident
itself for what it's worth we live in
what is typically considered a safe
neighborhood instead I wanted to share
share what I learned today about what
crimes are and aren't reported in San
Francisco it was eye-opening for me and
I hope it will be for you before
anything let me say that thankfully no
one was hurt sfpd arrived quickly on the
scene engaged the attacker in a calm and
safe manner afterward one of the
officers asked me if I like to press
charges being relatively unfamiliar with
this process I asked him to turn uh
intern what he advised to which he
replied that he would was prohibited
from influencing members of the public
on such decisions this was a this was a
sensible Pro this is a sensible
prohibition as one can imagine he says
if I didn't press charges the police
would issue a warning to the attacker
and in almost all cases that's enough to
scare offenders of this sort of way if I
did press charges I'd have to provide a
statement felt a good amount of
paperwork and then show up on the day
the attacker was is summoned to court if
he appeared not guaranteed the sentence
would probably be a slap on the wrist
someone involved with the campaign to
recall district attorney Bowden I was
thus faced with the Dilemma on one hand
I think it's our civic duty to report
crimes doing so was a bulwark against
sophistry employed by Bowden and his
supporters claiming that crime and SF is
down on the other hand if I did press
charges Bowden stats would show him as
having filed uh charges in this incident
or his more favorites that having taken
action despite the end result being the
same as if no arrests were made a
dangerous man free on the streets the
other complication I faced was that my
sister was with us visiting from abroad
and in town for just one day we were on
our way out to visit Museum and see the
city did he want to spend the limited
time she had with us filling out forms
so I decided not to press charges if I
did all over again maybe I would have
done otherwise but in the moment I had
to prioritize rapidly what's the upshot
of all this I've previously post about
how crime is trending up in San
Francisco and how bowdoin's attempts to
claim that crime is down or line a
misleading representation of aggregate
numbers
and so he goes on and you get the gist
of what the the story is and why I want
to get into it we were mentioning uh
George Soros funded DA's the breakdown
uh I could be wrong isn't isn't just
about in one of these DA's he was funded
by he received some contributions but
there were like 275 judges and DA's
across the country it wasn't just it
wasn't even just in in blue States it
was everywhere so you know to bring back
to the context of Gavin newsom's recall
we mentioned the Poo Patrol in San
Francisco you know so so there's
literally a department in San Francisco
that their whole job is just literally
going around cleaning up human waste off
the streets you know I can't blame Gavin
Newsom directly for that he's the
governor he's not a mayor he's not
dealing with the nitty-gritty but he was
the mayor of San Francisco well there
you go I was gonna say right now yeah
but yes and and uh your current vice
president was the the district attorney
of San Francisco as well I just I just
want to make it clear because when I'm
like recall him people are going to be
like he's not even the mayor of San
Francisco and it's like hold on hold on
I'm getting to the point is that all of
these people are part of the same party
that coordinates locally uh Statewide
nationally you have National level
Democrats coming in supporting policies
like they were trying to repeal the
Civil Rights Act in their constitution
right and you had National level
Democrats from other areas coming in and
supporting this absolutely insane and
now you have Gavin Newsome which
represents the fractured and broken
power structure that is California that
results in things like this so you think
he's an effigy then and not necessarily
individualistically to blame he's as an
effigy of what's wrong and removing him
is somehow symbolic no no no no no no no
no no no no no I think he's to blame for
a lot of this stuff I was just trying to
clarify like if you come out right now
and say you know that uh Gavin Newsom
should be recalled look at the crime in
San Francisco the immediate reaction
from the left is going to be like he's
the governor he doesn't deal with local
issues right right now I think that's
that's fair to point out he's been in
for what like three years has it been uh
yeah yeah yeah that's right yeah so I
think the issue is well for one you
gotta get rid of all of them you gotta
you gotta get all all these Democrats
gotta get voted well it's not just the
politicians though I mean it's the who
do you think Joe Biden's running the
white house right now it's probably his
chief of staff right no I think I do
think it's him I I struggle to believe
that because he can't string a sentence
together and that's the point yeah when
he's like they're not going to let me
answer any questions like he's actually
said that a couple time yeah but I think
it's him and so here's what people
assume they assume there's someone I
assume this for a while too that
someone's sitting there going like okay
Joe when you go up you have to do this
you have to do that and he's like oh
okay okay I don't think it's happening
what I think is happening is that Joe
sitting in the room you know is at the
the table oval table or whatever you
know it's people sitting all around
right and then they're looking at him
and he goes you know we got a
fghanistan get him out you know Bagram
get him out and then they go you got a
bus and they walk out and they evacuate
Bagram and the whole place falls apart
and then I don't so what I think by the
way from a finisher's thought and I'll
get into that I think what ends up
happening is you've got sycophant
sitting around just waiting for their
their turn hoping you know that like
there's no cohesive uh or structure here
that's a big problem in the military as
well the reason you're seeing all these
incompetent uh uh ineffectual General
officers is because of careerism they're
more interested in promoting their own
career than they are giving feedback
that might get them a negative response
that's what I'm being told from them
yeah for sure so these Chiefs of Staff
are like they don't want to go or they
no she's with these Joint Chiefs or
whatever they don't want to get fired
they don't get demoted right well it's
hard it's beyond yeah he can he they
serve the pleasure of the president he
can remove and replace them whenever he
wants uh but it's it's beyond that
what happened with James Mattis who was
a darling of the American Military for a
while I mean service members love this
guy for a while and uh then he was part
of this
what was it uh uh the 700 generals
General officers and Former Intelligence
people that wrote a letter against
Donald Trump supporting Joe Biden for
the election he was one of those guys
that did that and
um about a month afterwards he got hired
to the board of General Dynamics right
you know I mean it's it's weird so it's
it's well beyond just
the it's well beyond just the careers
and it's what that career turns into
afterwards Lloyd Austin
worked for a company right
and
that company was bidding on a
multi-billion dollar contract and the US
government had said that they're
probably not going to get it it doesn't
look good for them we're going to go
with the other guy and he becomes the
Secretary of Defense and I think about a
month later
or three months later that his his
former company gets that contract this
is weird so it's not just I get what
you're saying about removing all these
politicians but it that is the that is
the very top layer right of scum if you
want to call it well yeah so so I would
I would I would go into this and say we
have we have a structural Decay across
the board correct yeah when people are
willing to vote for no reason other than
tribe to earn points or because they
believe some garbage nonsense right or
in this instance you've got you know
people aren't reporting crimes because
what's the point I've been I've been in
the situation I'm sure you guys have as
well where it's like I had I had one
incident where uh me I was driving with
my brother and we got hit by a cab and
the cops were like you know okay we'll
we'll file all this but you guys are
going to show up right like you'll show
up to court if we do this right yeah
because they have to show up regardless
if you do it now yep and we were like
like okay let's do this and it's easy to
say at the time and then what happens a
month goes by and they're like okay
here's the date and time you got to show
up and I'm like dude I got I got work
yeah like I can't just sometimes years
man right if it's a yeah it's a serious
enough crime sometimes years go by if
they have a good enough attorney
sometimes yours go by so we've we've got
structural decree Decay across the board
in in every facet and so yeah maybe it's
fair to say just simply recalling you
know Newsome isn't enough it's it's good
I definitely think you know getting a
year of some someone else in there is a
good thing but you know you're talking
about the military I've heard I've
gotten emails we've heard a ton of
stories people resigning someone sent me
a resignation letter recently someone
apparently you know wasn't was an
officer and announced like over the over
over just the wokeness CRT and the vax
Mandate they're like I am quitting and
it's actually sad really because I've
heard these stories of people who are
like it was my dream to be you know in
to have a career in the military work
there until retirement and now it's like
I'm in my mid-30s and I'm out I'm done
can't do it right somebody some people
even giving up like their pensions which
it's super sad too because who's going
to fight this next War it's not going to
be these guys we saw in Afghanistan this
past a couple of weeks right
their work needed to get done and I have
no lack of faith in the 82nd Airborne
guys who were there or the Marines that
were there I'm sure I have no doubt that
they're plenty capable of doing that job
but because of the leadership there they
weren't allowed to do that right so
I wonder uh who's gonna fight the next
one and we we saw we saw the answer it
was guys like Tim Kennedy and these and
these other guys uh that went over there
on their own dime right guys that are
well Tim's still in but everybody but
him was already out of the military they
had served their country they were done
and they spent their own money to go
back to conduct these operations not to
go kill people or blow things up they
went over there to save people right
that's what the American war fighter
does they are they are and it it
troubles me that the the ranks of the US
service member have now been infected
with this nonsense oh yeah because I
don't know like you were talking about
police earlier I'm not sure how much
you can trust the individual at this
point you know what I mean it's getting
bad this this female staff sergeant that
posted a video like you know when people
are coming door to door that's going to
be me and I'll shoot you or whatever
like yep first of all you never held a
gun in your life and it's pretty obvious
but
that's a that's a she that's who they
want this Lieutenant Colonel gets booted
out of his position and then he resigns
this woman I don't know what's happened
to her have you heard any news about her
nothing
that seems like somebody that should be
immediately kicked out of the military
they want Storm Troopers they don't they
don't want rational thinking individuals
who are going to say like here's the
Constitution here's what might you know
you've got an officer that publicly said
she was gonna storm people's doors she
was a non-commissioned officer staff
sergeant E6 yeah well she didn't say she
was going to she said when it starts or
whatever she said I don't want to
paraphrase too much but she she
basically said the people going door to
door that's going to be me and I I will
that's terrible that's a form of Terror
she was like what do you think's gonna
happen when we're ordered to you know to
point you down it's not gonna it's gonna
be us and we're gonna do it instead
she's well what she says you refuse the
command
you know I I firmly believe and have
believed for a very long time that if
ordered most probably enlisted would do
it would absolutely shoot an American no
joke well we've seen it before right
Kent State it's it's happened in in our
parents lifetime 1970 May 4th I went to
Kent State for college they fired on the
crowd the national guard fired on the
crowd killed four college kids yep one
guy took a bullet through his own
through his hand no but uh so I've I've
you know been around military people for
for a large portion of my life and uh
there's a lot of people who argue with
me in chat or like an email and being
like you don't understand you know like
you know soldiers they'll do the right
thing they're not robots and I'm like
they're not robots it's the bystander
effect though right people people
psychology is infectious nothing is is
more infectious than psychology and
people in groups it's the mob we've been
to we've been discussing the psychology
of the mob for as long as human beings
have been discussing psychology the
Stanford Prison Experiment for example
you put people in hierarchical
structures of power and then mob rule
takes over and you go to base Instinct
that's what happens unless you're very
well trained but it when it comes to the
military it's actually really simple to
understand why this this this uh E6 you
said she's right they would do this you
know why it's really really simple
if if if Ian is running through the
streets with a red bandana on or
whatever maybe he's jogging that's right
and then she's standing there and she
gets an order like that's the guy he's
he's the terrorists take him down take
him down you think she's gonna be like
nah I don't know she shouldn't question
that order I mean she's going to be
alive about the military you're like if
I question the order are people gonna
die I mean we're talking about the born
identity right now right I guess the
third movie where he finally meets up
with the old guy and he's like is that
The Bourne Supremacy the prince yeah I
think or the born redundancy I think
yeah right right I'm not yeah but it
came down to like you got to shoot this
guy why and the reason was they wanted
to break the person right your
individualism is gone you thinking is
gone you can't who we tell you to kill
and that's not how it works that's not
how we trained our people in 82nd
Airborne you we we put ourselves at
Great risk on a relatively uh regular
basis to not inflict harm on people
unnecessarily right
can't say the same about Obama right the
Drone strike stuff killed a lot of
innocent people I think something like
30 of the people killed no strikes were
just standing there one of the first
things he did was bombing a village of
women and children I've heard numbers
that collateral damage of drone strikes
are like they started enormously large
like 90 but they started just claiming
that oh it's a military age male they're
an enemy combatant that's right yeah
anybody a military age male by the way
is a male 14 years old or older right no
so so I think people need to understand
this when you know when they when they
just reiterate to to a certain extent if
think about you yourself standing around
with your friends you hear you hear a
report like antifa's coming in they're
armed they got handguns you see what
just happened in Portland where they
were shooting at the proud boys
randomly like this was on like there was
no reason okay so they they were they
were retreating the proud boys like were
walking forward and they had like you
know clubs and shields or whatever
probably not a good idea regardless this
guy turns around with a gun and starts
randomly just firing and hits one of the
guy eyes in in the legs now imagine you
hear that and then all of a sudden you
see a dude with you know it looks like a
weapon and he's wearing all black and
then he's running towards you and and
then and they're like that's him that's
him stop and stop him are you gonna be
alike
it's not even just from your leadership
the Panic can happen in those situations
uh uh under any normal or any any number
of circumstances so this is we're
talking about the the one of the
founding moments of our Republic here
the reason that John Adams ended up
getting involved with the Continental
Congress and the movement towards uh uh
uh becoming America right and breaking
off for the British Empires because
there were British soldiers
in Boston and they were guarding some
areas there was a protest by the Sons of
Liberty which was run by his cousin Sam
Adams right not not the beer guy or
maybe he's the beer guy I don't know
um he was he was a politician but
Sam Adams is doing this thing somebody
behind the British soldiers uh well
first of all people are throwing heavy
objects and hit one of the kids in the
head and then somebody behind them
yelled fire yep right finally through
the trial they figured out and John
Adams represented the British people
yeah and he felt they got a good trial
they did they got off and then still the
crown sent over and edict saying all
military Court martials will now be
tried back in England
so he's like well you don't even believe
in our ability to self-govern now I'm
going to get involved and he became the
second president United States so this
stuff can happen in any kind of power
vacuum it doesn't matter if it's a
leader doing it or if it's just the fog
of war and imagine what the fog of War
looks like in modern day when it's
brother on brother right you know what I
mean yeah I think it's important to
realize that it's not evil when you know
this like a lot of people are
criticizing this young woman over saying
it and you know I'm I was I didn't
really want to do a big segment on that
because I'm like I don't know what the
full context is I don't know it's like a
five ten second clip or whatever who
knows what she's talking about it was
jump Cuddy and I'm like that's not much
I can add to that you know if she's if
there was like a 10 minute thing she was
talking about or there are other videos
where she was explaining why this
subject came up maybe there'd be more to
criticize right but I think you need to
you need to realize you're surrounded by
your buddies people you know people you
trust people who are there to protect
you and that's you that's your group
you're not going to sit around and wait
to find out when when you're dealing
with a conflict situation I I've been in
I've been in Conflict situations and I
don't sit back and be like well hold on
maybe this guy in the antifa thing who
was threatening us might not be antifa
no we leave we get out now if you're act
if you're there actively trying to
suppress or prevent violence and then
you see someone you're not just going to
assume well let's just call me talk to
this guy no this is why when I whenever
I've been arrested like legit arrested
by cops while covering things I've
always been released without being
processed like charges never occur or
anything like that because when I when I
was in DC on j20 in 2017 when Trump was
being inaugurated they surrounded
everybody I got trapped in this group it
was a bunch of antifa types I stood off
to the side and I I talked to the cop
like the cops that were standing there
with their batons out guarding everybody
I was like Hey I Just Wanna let you know
I'm a journalist and they're like don't
care then I'm like is there a supervisor
and then they're like some guy behind us
like I'll get a supervisor and I told
the super I was like hey I just want to
let you know I'm a journalist and he was
like doesn't matter you're all under
arrest and I was like just just letting
you know when I was talking to the cop
who was standing next to me because he's
guarding this group I'd be like officer
I'm going to place my bag down and I'm
going to be putting my shirt away and
taking my phone out just so you know and
then he'd like not a little bit and then
I would unzip it slowly I'd open it wide
pull out my phone put my shirt in
because he doesn't know who I am he's
not going to sit here pretending he
knows that I'm not antifa or whatever or
violent right that's a good thing that's
pulling out a club that's a very good
point why not in that scenario uh just
be
for the for the person who might be on
the threatened end of that exchange am I
really going to let my politeness get me
killed does that seem like a trade off
to you or could we as a society agree
that this is a messed up situation
neither one of us wanted it to come to
this but here it is so let's everybody
put your hands up and back away slowly
and then we'll go on our separate
directions or whatever right I mean it
seems like a reasonable way to handle
that but people get super emotionally
charred and look I'm not and listen to
that I get pissed off as much as anybody
else right yeah probably more so I lash
out all the time I've been in fights
with some of my closest friends over
nonsense like uh Alex Jones is one of my
closest friends we talk all the time he
actually just sent me some cool videos
of him shooting the other day
um he went pretty hard after some of my
buddies
at Black Rifle I thought he was out of
line and I said some things that I
thought also were out of line like and
and the funny thing is a lot of people
on the internet talk about it still two
days after that we were sharing photos
uh from respective lakes that we were at
you know what I mean it wasn't never
really a rift between us but but it gets
perceived like that and it's it's
unfortunate that it can come to that
sometimes and I think it's because
things get so heated we start to
prioritize the wrong stuff I think I
think we need to understand that there's
different uh bubbles than bubbles within
bubbles right so we have the largest
bubble of like America well technically
I say the large bubble of the world then
you have like America within the world
right then you have the different
regions different states different
cities within that there's different
Power structures different authorities
you always have that Trope of the of the
cop investigating a murderer and the FBI
guy walks in and goes we're taking over
jurisdiction yeah yeah the feds are
involved like uh Willem Dafoe and
Boondock suits yeah that's who the blank
I am or whatever yeah yeah yeah
excellent excellent performance but so
when it comes to you know Communication
Breakdown when you have things moving so
quickly it's ultimately going to be like
the people around you is the Paramount
to be protected and sometimes there's
even Friendly Fire between different law
enforcement divisions or there's one
funny story where like the DEA and the
FBI like busted each other oh yeah
setting up like a drug thing that's so
fun I'm glad that happened that's
as a taxpayer I don't love the fact that
taxpayer money was wasted but I guess if
it was wasted on them with each other
and not busting some poor guy that's
just trying to get high to be honest
yeah leave him alone but let's let's
talk about so we we I think we we got to
the point on that one but what happens
then when you take a confusing situation
where you've got people who want to do
and you add in
derelict leadership right talk about
this story check out the story all right
you're gonna love this from Fox News
White House abruptly Cuts feed of Biden
mid-sentence as he asks question at
wildfires briefing Biden's White House
has history of preventing public from
hearing him on the cuff it's not the
first time that after a presentation or
whatever people start asking questions
and the feed just abruptly shuts off no
it's happened numerous times I mean one
time he just he he actually made the
decision to turn around and walk off yes
well it was it all the time it was after
he was talking about the the storm and
they were like what about Afghanistan he
goes no we're not doing that and he just
walked out I mean say what you want to
about Trump I mean I I'm one of these
people that enjoyed Trump's policies for
the most part there are some things I
didn't like about it but the
the sometimes he just went a little it's
not even that he went too far I
understand why he's probably dead yeah
but it's at some point you have to be
like all right cool man
I'm just gonna get the message out there
and then keep doing this good work
because I you know what nobody's talking
about right now it is the historic low
historically low unemployment and for
black people in the country during Trump
you mean during Trump yeah nobody's
talking right now no of course not no
nobody's talking about how uh the five
major peace deals between Middle East
and countries and and Israel for the
first time in history right nobody's
talking about any of that stuff all
they're talking about is how he said XYZ
about the election and how he's behaved
since then yep I feel like if you're
that right about stuff and it's the the
results of his foreign domestic economic
policies were pretty good if you're that
right about stuff in principle I think
you have some responsibility to behave a
certain way to continue getting it done
but I do understand that he was under I
people like to to do these what about
isms and talk about who gets more heat
than whom I've never seen anybody get
trashed more or more regularly than
Donald Trump than the history of
American Media data proves it yeah I've
never seen it I mean it's it's wild do
it the Data Tracking negative negative
press for trump it was like 90 of
stories were negative and it was like
two to three times many stories than any
other why is that was he a real threat
to the power structure oh yeah dude of
course you think he he was look you had
you had Bernie Sanders and Donald Trump
the Insurgent candidates and Trump broke
through I don't know if any president
can can threaten The Establishment
anymore like Kennedy went down man he
said I'm gonna bust up the CIA and then
he died shortly after well I mean he's
always done it since Kennedy uh my
understanding is that the CIA clipped
him because of the Bay of Pigs because
he left he refused back there yeah oh
what's the story there the story well
you should have uh I know your fans
probably don't like him but you should
have Evan from Black Rifle come on he
worked for the agency for a while his
theory is that George H.W bush clipped
Kennedy because he was one of the
leaders of that operation Bay of Pigs
yeah yeah the the belief is that he was
a knock a non-official cover guy or like
a you know an operator and
the reason people believe that is
because he went from a congressman to
the deputy director operations which is
the most important job at the agency
like anything that happens there goes
through that office you know that you
know the challenge is with all that
stuff though is
how many assumptions you have to make
yeah yeah those aside I used to think
that I could get to the position of
President and then fix it I'll be I'll
get in there I'll get all the
information I'll finally fix it all so
that we don't have to worry about this
anymore but now I'm it's just it's such
a web that you get in there as this
piece the king piece the king's the
terrible piece in chess I mean it
doesn't it's not can't do it it's you
got to guard it because it's pretty bad
it's the worst piece oh well no the pawn
is the worst piece technically well it's
arguable pawns can transform but the
king's pretty terrible it just sits
there in hiding and waiting to be honest
I mean the president the king can move
one space in every direction it's not
bad okay but a little a little off topic
the president doesn't have as much power
as we we may think there is the queen
who's the queen in our society right now
I don't know Trump proved it Trump tried
to do so much and he was blocked he
should have fired way more people but
it's not I I don't need to get into
Trump right right the problem we have
right now is that people hated the guy
so much because the media hit him so
much because the establishment hated him
so much that now we we are we are at
lack thereof when it comes to a
president when it comes to leadership
right Joe Biden is here's the way I
describe it Donald Trump was
anti-elected the enthusiasm for Joe
Biden was in the gutter and all the
Trump supporters saying that was
evidence that Trump's going to win it's
going to be a landslide and Trump's
enthusiasm was through the roof yeah but
enthusiasm against Trump was through the
roof rivaling enthusiasm for him and so
people just voted for a jabbering
unwell man you know with vascular
dementia let's be real right Vasco
dementia and he and he would call a lid
call lid call lid and now they won't
even let him speak to you he tries to
answer questions and he goes I know I'm
going to get in trouble if I do this
remember when he was doing he was
calling on the press and then one of the
journalists I think was from PBS asked a
question and he goes I thought the
question was supposed to anyway
like he knew in advance what he was
going to be asking sometimes he's like
I'm not supposed to call on you but what
do you have to say yeah right like you
could tell like the old Joe Biden that's
still rattling around there somewhere
that likes a good scrap you know what I
mean he's just like all right come on
because that's again uh say what you
want about Trump but he would stand up
there and and talk trash back and forth
with the media all day if they would let
him yeah with Jim Acosta he would just
sit there and that would be the
presidency it would be four years of him
versus gem Acosta what kind of uppers do
you think they got Joe Biden on so that
he can do these these events be it's got
to be like B12 and Adderall right you
know mainlining that stuff under his
into his body there's no there's no way
he's
he he goes from this uh like hunched
over
guy that looks like he should be in an
old rickety uh FDR era wheelchair with a
with a shawl in his life to a guy who's
like alert and bright but he's a little
too alert and he's giddy about he's got
like what I mean they've been Main Line
in modafinil and then like his doctor's
like he's talking to Kamala we can't
keep pushing him like this his blood is
20 modafinil I saw a good uh I saw a
good it's only keeping him away for
three hours at this point I saw a good
meme today it was uh like comma you have
to stop answering the phone did he die
yet oh geez it's a little it's a little
dark it's very disturbing that we have
this this this guy in charge of the
military right now bro it's like
Afghanistan surrender I'm far less
concerned about him being in charge of
military as I am uh Millie and Lloyd
Austin bro these guys are human garbage
why is that look here's here's why let's
go back to this uh you you mentioned
Bagram earlier
a a private the lowest rank in the US
Military and the 82nd Airborne which is
who deployed over there uh along with
the Marine Corps would know that what
they did strategically makes no sense
right removing your so the the thing
that is unique about the United States
military uh aside we have a great Navy
we have nuclear capabilities we have
very well trained operators and soldiers
and Marines and and such but our air
superiority is where we really dominate
it doesn't matter who attacks us even
China at their advanced level right now
could not compete with us in their
superiority we remove our number one
piece we removed Our Queen off the board
in Bagram
and then what we had to redeploy I mean
the people that from the 82nd that went
there they're they're part of What's
called the drf1 the division ready for
us they're on they're on standby to
deploy at any time within 18 hours and
that's not a game plan that's that's the
backup that's that's the break case of
emergency situation you don't do that so
when they went there and then they just
sat inside of the base waiting for
something to happen also not what you do
the 82nd Airborne goes in and secures
the Airfield and then typically uh
Rangers and sometimes Marines maybe uh
Rangers go
push out Crete standoff and then
something like jsoc will conduct
operations in the area right that's how
that works and I know Millie knows this
because he was in Panama where we did
exactly that
right in 1989. like he knows all this
stuff so the fact that
these plans that Biden had and this is
why by the way excuse me
this is why the armed services committee
has now requested or demanded rather
that Lloyd Austin give them his plan
right for the Afghan extraction like
what the hell was this yeah this doesn't
make any sense yeah have you ever seen
Congress demand the plan from a military
commander before because it didn't make
sense no not my Lifetime right so
the question is why now we're seeing it
I Dakota Meyer and I were talking about
this
on our show and people
we set it in the mainstream media a
couple places and people were like no
that's not happening and and and and one
uh lady in particular tried to go after
us about it the pre our idea was this
uh and it's not an idea it's stuff we
heard from people the idea is that
the reason that Biden was so sure when
he said we're going to get all our
people out the reason that he had this
stupid plan in the first place the
reason that he gave up a list of
American citizens to the Taliban is
exactly what you saw yesterday so we
predicted that this past weekend going
into this week you would see airlifts of
U.S citizens coming out of Afghanistan
and you would see pallets of cash going
in
so
Saturday and Sunday two planes full of
American citizens leave today it's now
64 million or billion dollars is going
back to the to Afghanistan are we going
to pretend like that's not the Taliban
like we did just give them 64 billion uh
more dollars on top of the 80s this was
this was always assumed to be the out
the outcome with uh with the current
leadership of course lack thereof when
it comes to but the problem for me is I
get all the politics and stuff like that
but how did that military plan go all
the way up the chain of command and then
all the way back down to the people who
executed the plan without anybody ever
seeing anything
it's a million it's 64 million 64
million excuse me sorry how did it go up
and down the chain without that's a good
question it's it's it's internal rot you
know look man that we had that Professor
earlier the story came out where they
compared she said 911 was an attack on
hetero patriarchal you know what
capitalism or whatever yeah yeah
Syracuse Professor you've got absolute
systemic institutional Decay and we talk
about how the left dominates
institutions but I'm sorry what what I
really see happening is just there's
there's interested groups knocking down
the United States period think about it
this way there are people right now
cheering for Joe Biden's illegal
mandate that bypasses the legislative
branch he's already attempted to bypass
the legislative and the judicial with
his eviction moratorium and you have
people cheering for it that's basically
like the U.S system of governance has
been has been corrupted and is breaking
apart and they're celebrating do you
think it's happening I mean the only way
this could be more perfect is If instead
of Biden it was Joe Lieberman right
because he looked like Emperor Palpatine
do you remember that guy is everybody
remember any women from president yeah
he was from Connecticut I think 2008
what did he run uh I believe it was 2000
or 2004 it was in the primary I remember
that guy yeah he looked like Palpatine
but this is this is that's what's
happening here it's very bizarre and I
guess it always kind of happens that way
where uh
I mean it's the only time that that
authoritarian movements are ever
actually effective is when you convince
the population that it's for their own
good first right and that is they accept
it but I think what we're seeing now is
that people don't care about what is
right what is wrong they just want to
feel good and so they want to do
whatever the tribe tells them to do
right and so that's why you have the
social currency yeah like I think one of
the one of the like the best examples of
this is Cameron Caskey because I've
interact with them and maybe it's unfair
only because I haven't interacted with
other more bad faith actors but he
tweets a whole lot of stuff he's one of
the Parkland kids he tweets a whole
bunch of stuff out about getting
vaccinated and vaccine mandates and then
when I reply in good faith it's all just
garbage nonsense games to him you know
he tweets garbage nonsense he doesn't
respond so he's he's really interested
in inflaming tensions and and causing
strife and then when you try and like I
I I politefully dm'd the guy and been
like hey you know just wanted to just
flag this for you and he does he's like
I don't care he's like I'm not gonna
engage with you on this stuff literally
don't care and then starts insulting and
Screen grabbing insulting my followers
and I'm like I thought this dude was was
more interested in actually
accomplishing something but you can see
I think one of the big problems we have
with with this country right now is
there are young people on the left who
are 100 demoralized 100 right so they
grew up these younger people grew up at
a time with an economic collapse parents
who are probably struggling that they
themselves unable to find work deciding
to go to college now have massive debt
once again we get another crisis and
they're like why should I care about the
world let it burn for all I care and
that's what they do they go on Twitter
they start Twitter fights and they don't
care about solutions they just want pain
they want it to burn and the three of us
have acknowledged that we like to troll
or that like I was a big internet troll
from like 2009 to 2016 and I realized
how much damage I was doing seemed
subtle I was getting a good laugh out of
it but I think it was really messing
people up yeah I mean that that's
certainly uh
I there's there's something fun about
trolling because you need irony right
fundamentalism lacks irony that's their
problem like the the idea that you can
uh the the verboten thing like comedy
and the Arts are important but I'm not a
peg I'm not talking about trolling you
know look being sarcastic silly and and
posting on Twitter in ways that are
trying to make a point oh no this kid
you're talking about is just a
knucklehead he doesn't he's only
hundreds of thousands of followers he's
only trying to make a point he doesn't
care about the cause he's not trying to
make a point no no no he's not that the
point is he's not trying to make a point
he's trying to start yeah right so yeah
the way I see it is I mean I I I guess I
can understand it to a certain extent
you know they they grew up in a world
that was on fire and the system is is
corrupt and broken and so it's like why
should I bother with it it's like
there's nothing to look forward to when
you when when you're born into the
corrupt the the Chang system and so all
they do is add to the fire yeah I mean
what's the what's the quote from the
Matrix hope is the quintessential human
emotion both the source of our greatest
strength and weakness or something like
that I mean certainly if you imagine Mel
Gibson in The Patriot with his weird
haircut and his tricorner hat coming
over the hill waving the flag of telling
people to charge
who is that in American society right
now who isn't just sitting around
bitching and crying about the state of
things who's who's saying you know what
guys we can actually do this like the
only reason any of these politicians
have any powers because we allow that to
happen you're telling me that 535 people
plus the president and his staff and
Washington are overpowering 350 million
people that is physically impossible but
people are unfortunately That We're a
nation of cowards and absolutely well I
don't know if I don't know if we're
initiative cowards I think no no uh what
I mean I'm not calling everyone in this
country cowards no I I understand I
understand what you mean I think we have
a large quantity of cowards in this
country there's a George Bernard shock
and it's liberty means responsibility
that's why most men dread it right and I
think it's like when you we do it for
social reasons too you walk by someone
and they trip a little bit and you
divert your eyes because you don't want
to get involved in that I don't want to
feel a collective shame because
something just happened or whatever and
if you look at a piece of garbage on the
ground and then you look back up and
keep walking
shopping cart test you know the shopping
cart test uh yeah yeah where you leave
it out
in the you can you can you can you can
tell like the I guess I'll be a little
bit more
um
grandiose you can tell the strength of
the community by how many shopping carts
are strewn about the uh the shop the
supermarket that's kind of like Broken
Window Theory right I mean I guess in
the inverse of that for those that
aren't familiar it's basically
returning a shopping cart to the Corral
takes very little time if any it doesn't
reward you with anything it's just the
right thing to do correct you can also
run and jump on it and ride it it's fun
but you'll notice you'll go to some
places and their shopping carts just
piled up all over the place because
people go to their cars push it to the
side and say I don't care it'd take you
only 10 seconds to do the right thing
same thing with littering so I hate
that's what one of my pet peeves is when
people litter yep that that is the I I I
see you I agree with that principle the
shaman card principle and I agree with
what you're saying right now just for
that reason because I could feel it like
just do the right thing when people
cross in the middle of the street and
don't go to the crosswalk that's 20 feet
away that makes me mad you know what I
mean did you do it's we we set it all up
for you to do it right so when you're
safe so the driver's safe so everybody's
safe and you because what if you felt
like it you just not that I like look no
Scruples it's it's about it's not about
following the rules it's about personal
responsibility like if we're gonna put
so much weight on personal
responsibility my body my choice Liberty
I want to do what I want to do then do
the right damn thing but there's there's
I think there's a there is an we are a
country of people who refuse to accept
their responsibility I'll put it that
way and that's true for the left and the
right you know people have quoted Thomas
Paine let there be trouble in my day so
that my children will know peace and the
number one thing I hear over and over
again and did for years as to why people
would not stand up against the Tyranny
was I don't want to put my kids at risk
right so it's like two years ago when I
said they are coming to your workplace
they are going to come after you they're
going to subject you to this and your
kids they're gonna they're doing this
you know the things they're going to do
to your kids in the schools you've got
to speak up now before it's too late and
people be like look I don't want to lose
my job I got to feed my kids okay we're
not at the point where we're seeing all
these Twitter messages pop up people are
like I lost my job because of the
mandates right it wasn't my job you know
I'm like my kids I'm trying to pull them
out of school now because of the CRT
stuff oh no the board members they're
pushing CRT and they're voting against
us what do we do and I'm like
well I would say right now start
speaking up and just keep in mind that
if you would have spoken up two years
ago and all and got all your friends
together and was active about this it
may have never happened in the first
place
yeah I completely agree with that I mean
look
there's we're we're at the precipice now
I mean it's I don't know if uh
I I hate hyperbole I hate how
the word Nazi gets thrown around a lot
it's very irritating because there are
still people alive who went through that
stuff and I guarantee you they would not
associate what they went through with
anything that's happening right now on
both sides there are survivors accusing
the other side of being the Nazis yeah I
mean it's it's
what are we talking about here man I
mean we can't have a reasonable
conversation people have have grown to
the point where they think that their
opinion about facts are themselves the
facts right so we're not even having
we're not even speaking the same
language anymore you say racist and you
mean something that you you meet
somebody that genuinely hates other
people and then somebody else says uh
racist and they mean a power structure
that's been created over the last four
years yeah but that's a good point we're
not even talking about right thing no no
you know that's that's a great point we
talked about that years ago that the
debate happening was words mean didn't
mean the same thing right and that we'd
have to agree on common definitions
we're well past that point oh yeah I
don't know if we'll ever be truly past
that no no we're past important not
always Divine racism you know no no yeah
racism and they'll say it's a Confluence
between power and racial Prejudice okay
so in 2014 with all the gamergate stuff
happening
and then into 2015 it's an escalated
2016 we started seeing physical conflict
with Trump I was saying based off of
what tons of other YouTubers had already
said I'm like clearly people aren't
speaking the same language when you're
having this debate the left is arguing
racism means Prejudice plus power
intersectionality and the writer's
argument means discrimination the basis
of race the point we're at now in 2021
is that I can sit here and say like I'm
pro-choice and then have someone who's
conservative say I'm pro-life and I'll
say okay we understand what that means
let's have a discussion on the ethics
and morality of how this plays out in in
U.S governance and what's the right
thing to do the left says we will
literally claim words mean something
else just so that we can claim we won
the debate right that's it's not about
it's not having the same definition it's
about them actively changing words on
the fly on purpose I'm sorry it's about
Miriam Webster changing the definition
of the word racism changing the
definition of the word anti-vaxx
specifically changing what the word
immunity means just so that like people
can win a political art argument they
are actively trying to confuse you so
that you don't understand what they're
arguing well they're not arguing for
anything that's Brave New World right I
mean it's it's that and removing words
well Brave New World was was keeping
people locked down by Pleasures oh not
pretty new world uh uh in 1984 1980 they
start removing words so right instead of
good and bad it's good and not good like
but it's one where ungered or whatever
that's good you know that's right it's
it's uh uh what is it a a brave new
Fahrenheit 1984 I know that's what we're
living in yeah yeah but it's what what
role do you think the fact that there's
absolutely no tolerance at this point
for anybody to be wrong at any point
about anything you know what I mean you
you said you didn't like the word Nazi
being thrown around right because it's
like you know I think the challenge with
the word Nazi is you say Nazi and then
say oh well why is it like the Nazis say
fascist or communist or whatever and
they try it those were words that were
specific to ideologies in the early
1900s in Europe and things like that and
and yes they had prominence in other
places but we need we need new words to
describe what the left is authoritarian
yes but it's something specific
authoritarian identitarian communist
they're like they're Kami Nazis you know
the Kami Nazi fascists it's a little I
mean because there's social programs
sprinkled in there but it's also very
identity driven and it's also very
corporate so how do you define that I
mean they took all of the all of the
tenets of authoritarianism and kind of
combined them into one and we've it is
very I argue with uh I was arguing with
someone about this is it is what the
left is today is very very very close to
Nazism not the same thing but what was
what was what was Hitler doing he was
trying to steal back land he claimed was
rightfully German oh now you've got the
left arguing you we just had a terrorist
convicted for trying to derail trains to
seize the land back for the indigenous
they're identity based okay they're not
the same when it comes to Nazism like
Aryan they're very anti-white but
they're still identity based
authoritarian they use fascistic ethos
like there is no truth but Power there's
a lot of similarities so I suppose the
issue is they'll always try and deflect
by claiming you're the Nazi when you
know I love it you have the Gadsden flag
don't tread on me literally saying leave
me alone and you know I'll leave you
alone don't don't come near me that's
what it meant by the way and they have
the flag of the fists the Communist fist
squeezing the snake saying we will try
and I'm like you're the it's a fashion
it's amazing to think that this because
the Nazi party is a real political party
I think there's American Nazi party
isn't there there's like a socialist
American party uh the Amer the national
Associates of America the NSA yeah they
were big in the 1930s obviously or
actually the 1920s it was uh it was big
on the East Coast so so these people
their hatred for that has turned them in
to that which they yeah how often does
that happen no no it's pretty common
it's written about I think my opinion on
this is that the current iteration of
the establishment left and many of their
you know more Progressive and DSA type
um sycophants is just what happens when
you get behavioral sync and cultural
what happens is oh yeah that makes a lot
of sense it's just part of a system this
is a function it's just kind of I mean
there's only it's just a fire there's a
there's only one way to turn right I
mean it's you turn to tribalism and it's
like uh the Stanton paper the uh the
stages of genocide like how all that
stuff progresses from from uh uh let's
see I actually have it somewhere on here
let me see oh this probably happened for
tens of thousands so just just to go
through some of these quickly
classifications the first one people
divided into them and us I mean come on
man uh uh symbolization when combined
with hatred symbols may be forced upon
uh unwilling members of pariah groups
like The the star the knots or like uh
maggot and all this stuff or even name
calling yeah we're not going to get into
that because I don't want to get you
flagged here but uh discrimination
happens which is you know the the what
is it people already being fired we're
referring to it now as the uh as the uh
the pandemic of the unvaccinated even
though there's no scientific basis for
any of that nonsense right it's it's
Kamala Harris said in a tweet recently I
think it was today we must protect the
vaccinated and I'm like but they are
over vaccinated right I don't understand
what that means so if if protective
vaccinated from whom they're vaccinated
so they're not talking about protect
them from covet clearly
I don't know what it means but I think
she did mean covert which is silly if
she did then she doesn't no you can't
assume that but what that that's the
that's the issue that you got to watch
out far with con artists con artists use
something called assumptive language so
they can say a thing to make you believe
something without actually ever having
lied but if you challenge them on it
they're like well I don't know right I
mean they always back pedal people don't
the next one after that is
dehumanization uh like I don't know
deplorable right right that was just
what an incredible stupid thing to say
actually somebody uh it wasn't Rolling
Stone maybe it was The Daily Beast
somebody ran a story a week or two ago
and it said Hillary's biggest mistake
was calling people deplorables but was
she right or something like that you're
kidding me really you're writing that
right now are you trying to stoke
conflict I mean obviously they are but
yeah asking rhetorically uh these things
these distance novels were not a a a a
guidebook we was a warning we went
through the the stages multiple times
and I think we've like in some instances
we stop it too there's like 10 right 10
is like Erasure of the genocide nine is
genocide right when it comes to the
vaccine stuff it's starting to feel like
it's getting crazy because you have them
saying plague rats you have them saying
like we must protect the vaccinated it's
very like they're literally classifying
they're literally talking about
quarantine and things like that and so
it seems like that is the dangerous
territory But ultimately what I was
saying about what the modern iteration
on the left is right now I'm calling it
fire what I mean by that is an ignition
started at some point and there was no
one willing to take responsibility to do
anything to stop the fire put it out so
it's been growing and growing the bigger
it grows the harder it is to put it out
eventually becomes impossible to put out
and then it sweeps over everything it is
a chaotic and destructive force with no
goals the best example one example I
love using is the word wimixen
w-o-m-x-n you ever hear this word no so
there was an organization that said we
must respect all wimixen and wimixen
means the inclusive word for women
a bunch of feminists and leftists oh I
see it's like latinx but with X oh my
God so they started getting attacked
saying why do you need a different word
for women are you acting like trans
women aren't women and need a different
word to include them
simultaneously the word woman and women
were both the offensive and inoffensive
versions there was not it was not
possible for you to use the right word
right no matter what you use someone
would come after you for violent intents
because there is no goal there is no
good there is only we will destroy
now let's do this let's jump jump over
to our good friends in Australia and let
me clap back at uh the Australian I mean
it's getting wild out there so uh
Australia is in the process of building
more camps which they already have
several of these are camps with
relocatable cabins they say for
quarantining people who are as they say
when they're coming from abroad they
need to be placed into this Camp into a
bungalow to be kept safe
so that they can't infect people with
covet oh be protected and they have to
wait there now I refer to this as a
concentration camp why
because the word concentration camp
doesn't literally mean Nazi death camp
right and there is some
um
you know you you are trying to evoke an
emotion by saying concentration camp I
did not choose those words lightly I'm
literally trying to point out what's
happening the government of Australia
has built camps they are putting people
in those camps they are claiming it's
for safety this is step one in the 100
step process towards locking up people
sealing them in and then letting them
die will it get to that point maybe not
no idea but when has the government
built camps with relocatable cabins for
people deemed suspected of having a
sickness to be to be locked away for a
short period of time when has that
turned out well I want to just clarify
you're exactly right on the definition
of concentration camp it's a camp where
large numbers of persons such as
whatever political prisoners whatever
are detained for the purposes of
concentrating them in one place exactly
that's what that means the death camps
were very specific type of concentration
camp not common right and so you're
trying to evoke an emotion by calling it
a concentration camp obviously or of
course but quite literally it's just
when people are concentrated in one
place which is what they're doing now
I will I will uh as much as I typically
don't like doing this I'm gonna actually
just call out Colette and Claire Lehmann
specifically because I used to be a big
fan and now I think they are one of the
most they're one of the perfect examples
quillette and Claire of how you get the
Nazis so you look at Nazi Germany and
people would say like how did it get so
bad no it's really simple when the
people who are claiming to be the
intelligent dissidents started
apologizing for the actions of the Nazis
any reasonable dissent was gone and it's
probably because they were scared of the
state they were scared of being included
in as an undesirable or as unclean or
being labeled they were scared recently
we've seen with the opposition to
critical race applied principles in
schools Claire Lehman of quillette Kathy
newmaning James Lindsey meaning she
takes things he says greatly out of
context to try and smear him which is
really weird because why would you do
that he's talking about American
political issues and there's no reason
to take what he's saying out of context
recently when I tweeted concentration
camp in response to the camps they're
building in Australia Claire did a tweet
saying that I called them death camps
which is again out of context or just
hyperbolic and then criticized me which
ended up now in the Australian as I'm
told one of Murdoch's Australian papers
now in this article
she says mocked we may be but compare
the death rates this is Claire Lehman
Colette supposedly supposed to be
classically liberal challenging the
wokeness The Establishment defending the
authoritarian practices of Australia a
video of a man being taken out of a
hotel because there's a Manhunt because
he didn't quarantine and he was seen
sneezing in an elevator
there's a video and we have it of a guy
who they they show up to his house with
the police in full gear and is confused
it's what's happening they said he's
being taken to a hotel quarantine
indefinitely
News 9 Australia saying this
when you have police strung into
people's homes and saying we're going to
quarantine you then they say we are
building we've built camps and we will
build more camps at what point do you
say I kind of don't trust the government
doing this
do you think that when the Nazis started
building these camps they went out and
told the public what their intention was
no of course not well I mean the
presumption is if you believe the
stories that we read uh when the 101st
Airborne first Came Upon one of these
camps that was the first that anybody
except for the people that lived nearby
that saw the ashes of bodies burning
going by their homes like those people
in The Villages knew but the like people
in Munich they had no idea allegedly
anyways right well so the propaganda is
you can look back at it one of the uh
the famous bits of propaganda from the
Nazis was that the Warsaw Ghetto for
instance the Jews carried typhus and for
the sake of the health you know we
needed to get in there and we need to do
something about it that's what they were
doing so they they they pull up in the
trucks they say get on the train cart
and then when I see a video of a guy
with the cops showing up and they're
like it's time for your indefinite
quarantine he's like all right mate I'm
like that guy did not learn a single
thing from history now I'll admit it's a
big challenge what do you do when
multiple Cops show up quarantine ready
to take you in it's like man
I'm not going to presume to be the arbit
of morality on this one to tell you what
you should or shouldn't do but I will
say it's shocking for us nonetheless to
watch a video out of Australia where a
guy says he apparently let me let me
jump to this uh this tweet
um now I will admit first and foremost
there's video it says News 9 exclusive
nothing comes up people have been
searching for this guy's name because
like the search algorithms Show you
people are searching for this guy's name
but nothing comes up from News 9 and I
don't know the original Source on this
video but this man says you can see him
the cops show up to his house they're
wearing gear he says he got a covid test
just for peace of mind never got alerted
to what happened until one day the cops
showed up saying he was positive and
would be taken in for an indefinite
quarantine I don't know what happened to
this guy or where he's ended up but why
would anyone look at that and say that's
fine that's normal now to throw it back
to Colette what they what what happened
so what uh clay lemon has written for
the Australian she briefly mentions me
saying in the opening paragraph the
international media Spotlight has been
shining on Australia lately and not in a
good way last week the left-leaning
Atlantic magazine published an article
that asked rhetorically if we were still
a liberal democracy no Australia is not
you uh that's me adding that in she goes
on to say us TV host Tucker Carlson told
his audience of 3 million viewers
Australia has descended into
totalitarianism which it has and on
social media popular use us YouTube
personality Tim pool likened our
quarantine facilities to concentration
camps they then show a statement from
this guy Josh zeps of uh he's an
Australian broadcasting uh broadcast or
whatever he says repurposing Outback
mining accommodation into international
arrival Bungalows is not the same as
running a concentration camp literally
by definition it is concentration camps
are bad because they brutalize political
prisoners not because they look ugly in
aerial photos this is what I said about
the Kathy newmaning now to be fair like
I I think we all know concentration camp
evokes a kind of memory not see what
Jeremy was doing but I used that phrase
specifically not to imply that Australia
has been rounding people up and beating
them and executing them though I do
think people they are being mistreated
as we've seen in some of the videos
but just listen to what he's saying
repurposing Outback mining accommodation
into international arrival Bungalows
it's more than that they're getting
people from their houses as well it's
not just International now hold on that
video they say hotel quarantine it seems
like that was before they had the camp
set up and they were putting people in
hotels but here's my point on that
Canada's doing that still right the
hotels yeah so this guy is look they
build camps
they literally built camps to
concentrate people right we were we were
just tired it was a huge conspiracy
theory uh the FEMA camp thing right that
never happened in the west that would
never happen here like it's literally
happening right now well so here's my
point this guy starts you know tweeting
you know I I love how absolutely
pathetic quillette has become I mean I
mean that someone I'm being sarcastic
it's it's sad There was an event we did
I was at Milwaukee and I met Claire and
I was excited I'm like well that does a
great job it's a very rational
reasonable it's anti-authoritarian and
now they are literally dropping to their
knees and gagging on boot
when you have videos of a guy sneezing
in an elevator and then a Manhunt and
they find him and they're dragging away
in this full gear while people cheer for
it when you have a video of a guy being
taken from his house for a hotel
quarantine it's not about whether or not
they are actively putting those people
in camps it's about they've created
camps to concentrate people as they come
into the country they're building more
of them the the Brisbane Brisbane how we
pronounce it Camp isn't expected to be
finished until mid-202 Brisbane Brisbane
so what does that mean Brazil Brizzy
they do not expect that they do not
expect the pandemic to end until
sometime after mid-2022 because I really
doubt they're building a camp to just
shut down immediately or not use it all
it's very likely they will use it like
they're using these camps if they're
already willing to show up to someone's
house and take them away for a
quarantine why wouldn't they eventually
just say well we have these quarantine
facilities they're better than the
hotels it's cheaper for everybody so
we'll just put them in the Bungalows
it's just a bungalow what's the biggest
yeah you're gonna get pushback that
they're not camps you'll probably start
hearing that they're not caps Tim well
okay they're quarantine facilities
that's the literally they're
concentration facilities and it's the
same thing and that's the point I'm
making with what he said except they
call them relocatable cabinets home
whatever no no no yeah their cabins
concentration cabins well no no the
point is campgrounds have cabins oh
you're right yeah this is all this is
all political messaging though how
quickly did the phrase kids in cages
switch to whatever the Obama or the bite
Administration uh we're calling them and
and the the circumstances were far worse
by the way I don't know if you've seen
I'm sure you have you've seen these
pictures right of the kids under the
bridge of of kids rolled up in in
thermal blankets it was bad when it was
under Trump but at least Trump was
actively saying we gotta end this this
which is by the way is the same thing
that Hillary Clinton was seeing as
Secretary of State in 2013 exactly that
right do not come here and and and and
and Bernie yeah but let's let's I'm
gonna throw back to Australia and make
this point in the United States we saw
black lives matter marching to the
street shoulder to shoulder no masks and
the media said it was fine they're not
super spreader offense because we say so
just happened motorcycle rally not even
overtly political for the most I'm sure
there was politics there but for the
most part it's a motorcycle rally super
spreader event protesters on the state
capitol ground stairs super spreader
event we get it Obama can have his big
birthday party and everything's fine
even though people did get sick black
lives matter can protest and it's fine
what do you think is going to happen in
Australia with these people protesting
the quarantines how long until the
police say well this quarantine was a
super spreader event so we're going to
start putting these people in quarantine
for their own safety you're developing a
mechanism for the get retribution
against people politically and so this
guy tweeted at me and said when that
starts happening I'll admit I was wrong
and I'm like and therein lies my point
that you would let it happen before you
would do anything about it and I would
say hey don't let them do it quillette
your cowards
first they came for the uh
socialist and I wasn't a socialist so I
didn't say anything then they came for
the trade unions that wasn't a trade
unionist and didn't say anything so then
it came for the Jews I wasn't a Jew so I
didn't see anything and then they came
from me and there was no one left to say
anything that's a very good poem yep man
it's and by the way even the data she's
talking about is nonsense she's look at
our numbers it's it's we're we're lower
than if we had lost as many the
percentage of the United States did do
you know how many there's so many
countries Sweden uh forget about Sweden
uh Panama Lithuania Nepal Libya Botswana
Ireland Switzerland Georgia Nigeria the
Republic of the Congo have lower case
mortality rates than Australia to be
kidding me to be fair I'm sure that the
people of Australia have never heard of
Benjamin Franklin oh yeah and you know
we were fortunate enough to have
Benjamin Franklin who said those that
would sacrifice some sacrifice Freedom
First for temporary security deserve
neither and will lose is covert wrecking
like third world I don't like using that
word third world countries are less
industrially developed is covered
wrecking them or is this an obesity
crisis like in the first world there's
two points to be made on third world
countries or underdeveloped nations one
um there's there's not much data at all
saying that there's large numbers of
deaths and if you look at a lot of the
the the charts and everything you'll see
nothing happening the second point is
they don't have the infrastructure for
tracking a lot of this stuff so
countries with underdevelopment medical
infrastructure aren't tracking I would
also say some of the more I mean once
once the the first wave rolled through
there there's no guarantee that uh a
Delta variant would pop up independently
in that place and how many people are
traveling to third world countries you
know what I mean right so less travel
less population density means less
spreads which probably mean they reached
uh the fact that they have less access
that they're more crowded together and
have less less access to modern medicine
probably means they reached a higher
percentage of natural immunity faster
than any other place right you would
think so even when even necessity even
when it even when a new variant popped
up they would be more protected I mean
everybody knows at this point that the
coveted vaccine treats the spike protein
right primarily
right it's it triggers an immune
response to the spike protein right so
but there's 28 other proteins on the
covet cell right so if you I'm I'm
telling you that that red that red
circle with all the stuff coming off of
that you've seen in the news and stuff
those are all little proteins right the
spike protein is the one that's being
treated because that's the one that was
causing us issues the other 28 are not
are they're treated to some degree by
this because of the triggered response
but nowhere near as effective as natural
immunity and we see this in this Israeli
study it's 800 000 people yeah you don't
get much bigger than that when it comes
to a medical just as the human brain is
greater than any computer we've ever
built I imagine our immune system is
stronger than any medicine we could ever
administer I would imagine I don't know
but I mean the most incredible
mechanical the most protected you could
be is to have had covet survived it and
also been vaccinated right yes right
there's no question about that what are
they calling that the super immunity and
in order to develop immunity it's about
consuming the right products including
vaccines and food and all these things
so it's not like it's not a black and
white you know I would push back on your
Community thing because there are
diseases we could not treat or cure but
we could vaccinate against like if you
get rabies you die if you get bit and we
administer the vaccine fast enough
modern medicine's incredible not even
modern just medicine in general food but
is that a is that a prophylactic vaccine
though we don't get a we don't get a
shot for that before we get it well no
so the way the uh rabies works is that
once you get bit it has to go into your
nerve cells right when that happens
you're dead right so if you get bit and
you get the vaccine it prevents the
infection but that's not a prophylactic
vaccine no that's a regular vaccine yeah
so it's like and it's like six shots
like every day or not every day like it
was like every week for like six weeks
or something yeah wow in your stomach
destroys rabies
that's right I've grown pretty weary of
everybody comparing this to polio and
measles and smallpoxies which are very
very serious and they're of course they
are I mean polio in children was about
two to five percent but the the loss of
them are loss of use of your limbs was
pretty bad when you reach the adult age
it was somewhere between 15 and 30
measles somewhere between 10 and 15
percent uh smallpox twenty percent these
are nowhere close to point three percent
right people that died or people that
caught it mortality yeah yeah wow so
that that look that's like it's apples
and some fruit no one's ever heard of if
you're a fan of Arrested Development
yeah I think I think it's fair to say
that something
well Papas are great we have a whole
bunch of pawpaws yeah we do so I didn't
I didn't realize you know I thought we
only had a few but we went we have this
like wooded area as part of the property
and they're everywhere you step on them
it's like oh you shake a tree and they
keep falling in the head you're like
what the hell is this I feel like I'm in
a Sci-Fi novel or something yeah you
ever see a pop you've seen a pop-up
before oh yeah yeah
what were you talking about about how
um how are you enjoying this so much so
here's what I was gonna say I think it's
fair to point out that early on we were
like hey it's novel so it's gonna spread
rapidly because there's there's also
going to mutate more quickly right and
the mortality is like I think it's like
what double the flu or whatever uh right
around there yeah and so I'm like I
think it's a good reason to be worried
about this you know it's not the same
thing well if you're under 40 and
healthy then there's not a reason for
you to worry about yourself but you do
have some responsibility to the people
who are over 40 right right yeah we have
we we do bear some responsibility for
those around us in some way now I don't
bear a whole lot of responsibility for
somebody who's been stuffing uh sugar
and fat down their throat for the last
25 years well if that's okay it's a
sugar but when they're mixed it's really
good fat and sugar together sugar
together are not great but yeah it's
it's
I don't bear any responsibility for that
but I do understand like with some of
the I don't like being told what to do
and I think if this was a serious enough
problem people wouldn't need to be
that's the issue with Liberty right
if people typically Trend towards taking
care of one another yeah especially
Americans nobody gives more money
anywhere in the world than the Amer not
the American government the American
citizen so like when the uh when the uh
the storms happened in uh Indonesia
right and they had the tsunamis and all
that stuff nobody gave more money to the
Indonesian people than the American
citizen not the American taxpayer the
American citizen and this stuff pops up
all the time we see these people in
Afghanistan uh that need to get out
they're friends of ours people are
spending their own money to go over
there without Guns by the way these guys
were operating without arms going into
hostile territory grabbing people and
getting them out that is who people are
generally speaking let them be that let
them be good let them be American
because that's what it means to be
American in the first place you're
robbing another the honor of being that
thing and of course they're gonna turn
that's how it works I want to point out
something going back to this Australian
article that uh I think is important for
critical thinkers
there's a certain amount of trust you
can place in institutions based on the
credibility that they have and the
things they've done that you can track
and then make your assessment I
typically have a hard time trusting a
lot of the mainstream news outlets but I
if I can fact check them out if I can
find source material I will sometimes
you just blindly trust they're telling
the truth for instance you know one of
the Articles we use from KTLA earlier
was just quoting a woman and for all I
know they didn't actually call them when
I don't know so we do have trust in
these institutions I just think it's
kind of funny that if in this Australian
article they say the data says that you
know x amount of deaths in Australia and
you know ABCD if I'm criticizing your
government for building camps in which
they take human beings and place them
and then there's a video of a guy where
he's like you know we're waiting to be
fed one woman was yelled by the cops
because she was she took her Mast on a
sip T if I'm criticizing your government
for being authoritarian crackpots and
then you go yes but that same government
told us that it's important and we
should all do it I'm like isn't it kind
of like that's my point you're using a
word in its own definition yeah exactly
like doesn't make any sense if you
you're coming out being like the
government did this thing and then the
government told us it worked yes we
investigated ourselves and found we did
nothing wrong that's what they're doing
I'm all set on those actually it's it's
it's it's sad right I was talking to
some people about you know where how
where Colette has gone recently
particularly with Claire um moderately
prominent anti-sjw personalities or
anti-woke now she's just doing this
whole crypto woke thing what's that it's
where they'll be like I am not woke but
your criticism of the vocus is going too
far
so what they do is Weinstein gets into
that a little bit Yeah if you listen to
his interview with Erica with uh uh Eric
if you if you listen to his interview on
the poor on Portal with uh uh Douglas
Murray who's one of my favorite authors
by the way is a great great author uh he
wrote
um uh uh what is it The Madness of
crowds it's one of the best books I've
ever read if you haven't read the
Madison crowds I highly recommend it but
uh yeah that conversation he's like I
don't really like I understand where
woke is coming from and it's like dude
you don't
I understand nuance and conversation but
you do not that what you were talking
about earlier with the uh with the with
the Germans and how people and positions
of of authorities started being becoming
apologists or at least passively so for
this nonsense well I disagree with them
but yeah your criticism goes too far
what that does is it it it arms people
with it it gives them permission to say
oh well right and go on about their day
it's not that bad yeah what is it it's
just a camp anytime any any time you
have to utter the phrase it's not that
bad that's like a couple
uh starting a new Facebook account with
both their names in it somebody cheated
right you know something is up here
something has happened wrong and now
people are correcting for it you don't
make statements like that if it's good
and it was since when do we settle for
it's not that bad well the crazy thing
was this guy who was criticizing me
tweeted no one is being brought to these
camps and I'm like then why did they
build the camps like what are you
talking about there's people being
brought there there's like a guy
building a doomsday device don't worry
I'm never going to use this thing yeah
we built camps nobody's being brought
there I mean I guess maybe he's saying
no one's going to Australian people's
homes and picking them up to bring them
there yeah well there's video of that
too though so it went to the to the
hotels at least so like the intent is
there to bring people to camps when when
does when do people stop suspending
their disbelief I wonder I mean it's
it's like that I gotta tell you that
George Bernard Shaw Thing Once you open
your eyes you're responsible for what
you're seeing and that is a problem for
a lot of people we we had someone here
and then after the show ended and we
were like wrapping up and getting up to
leave they were like you you know you
really think there's going to be like
some kind of civil war or something and
I was like we're in it it's happening
yeah like no I think everything will be
back to normal and it'll calm down and
I'm like
what part of a thousand people broke
into the capital and fought with cops
and stopped the electoral college
process and there was a shootout in
Portland numerous times and the guy was
shot in the chest twice and there's been
ongoing skirmishes and the Capitol
Police are being expanded Nationwide to
start tracking down maggots and George W
bush is comparing right-wing individuals
in this country to the Taliban like what
part of all of that don't you say
there's a global civil corporate War
like it's a corporate there's a there's
a there's a the corporations have been
at war with the plebes for instance I
don't know when since the 1600s the
bankers wanted to just control the
system or something so I mean yeah it
was before that it was a war between the
the wardens and the King right it was
like uh uh you know between King John
and all the the Robin Hood story we all
know this right uh uh
it's it was all it was the levels of
aristocracy fighting against one another
everybody else was illiterate and
unarmed so that was that was King
Richard's brother John Richard left to
go fight in the Crusades and left his
brother in charge of this country and
John is notably a terrible terrible
leader correct makes me think about Joe
but a lot of times I think about Joe Bon
I think King John he's one of the worst
this and and John just just messed it
messed up the the country horribly badly
yeah he did end up signing uh a document
that gave rights to the wardens for the
first time but still not the Common
People sometime around the 16th 17th
century actual normal people started
getting rights people like John Locke
started talking yeah uh Martin Luther
started talking uh up from the religious
side a lot of stuff started happening
yeah it's been going on for a while so
what happens if people defeat the top
and then they get to the top and then
they stop fighting for the people below
them is that the been the they were
never fighting for people below them no
and that's a big problem too one of my
favorite quotes ever in the history of
of the world is from Martin Luther King
Jr said you have two hands for a reason
one to pull yourself up and the other
one to pull the next guy up with you and
if that is not the way we're intent on
living Our Lives we may as well just go
back to fighting in caves and [ __ ] you
know it's it's it's really simple Ian
you have someone who's looking around
saying why am I in this circumstance and
they decide to blame someone else or
they decide I can take from someone else
they can justify to themselves look at
all these other people in a similar
circumstance that's evidence that I am
correct once they get stuff they say
well why didn't you do what I did when I
fought to get my stuff
it's always for themselves they just
justify their plight or their their or
Justify their amoral actions by claiming
they're fighting for something greater
it's a fifth dimensional
Global corporate Civil War fifth
dimensional yeah fifth dimensional
Warfare what do you mean fifth
generational yeah I like calling it
dimensional yeah you're right
generational let's go yeah it is it is
both dimensional and generational but
it's a fifth generational corporate
Civil War globally yeah it's Mass
propaganda across the board I mean it's
I wonder I wanted to ask you about this
while I was here what do you think about
um
who who do you think before I Poison the
Well here who do you think benefited
most from our Afghan Excursion over the
past month right China yeah right uh
I I wonder so they're going to get
something like 150 billion dollars in
oil
um 1.5 trillion in lithium give or take
right uh 1.5 to 3 who knows it's
somewhere in that range and and not
adjusted for inflation
so
I hate to draw these weird connections
and stuff because there's a lot of
assumptions being made between A and B
but this whole uh 100 Biden barisma
thing that was completely buried by the
Press uh he's getting paid money by the
Moscow mayor's wife former wife I'm
sorry and and Joe Biden flew his son on
Air Force 2 to China for a billion
dollar private equity and there's the
big guy who's referencing intelligence
documents that's receiving some payout
the presumption is that it was Joe Biden
everybody was kind of went on about
their business
uh man well Bobby Linsky said it was
Biden yeah is it possible
and I I guess it is just Chinese
collusion yeah like is that is the is
the president I mean I I talked to Alex
about this Alex Jones uh last week and
he goes yeah I think 100 that the that
the presidency is compromised right now
is I agree if that's possible then what
the hell I agree if you look at um this
is well before Biden was President we
are investigating a lot of the stuff I
covered the burisma stuff to great deal
and boy did the media try to cover that
up Politico had reporting it was it's a
funny article where it says you know
Ukrainian Ukraine scrambles after you
know trying to to stop Trump or whatever
right and then it was based on those
some some Ukrainian officials in an
embassy were like leaking details on
manafort which got him in trouble and
then it was a few years later that
Politico reported that there was no
Ukrainian Collision it never happened
and I'm like but Politico never
retracted the first article they just
allow these two different authors to
contradict each other that's the state
of the media when when you see the
investigation by like Matt taibi into
the brisma stuff the stuff I've covered
from it I'm like before Biden was even
elected I'm like this guy is dirty
you've got political reporting in in
their magazine Biden Inc about how uh
Biden's family's wealth has tracked
perfectly along his career when he was
put in charge of Iraq his brother is
awarded all these contracts for building
in Iraq and now he's a millionaire and
things like that Hunter Biden being
flown in Air Force too to China and now
you have everything that's going on how
was Afghanistan botched to the degree
that it was botched sure is convenient
for the people who did a private Equity
or was I'm sorry we're negotiating a
private Equity deal I don't know if that
was actually confirmed as happening but
who knows you can't trust them so I just
think it's it's awfully convenient and
you know the problem is when it came to
Trump
and Russia gate I was saying like you
know I think we will look into it right
if it's true it's true if it's not it's
not and I you know we don't just throw
away evidence if we're seeing it we try
and dig deeper I said the same thing now
about Joe Biden the only problem is the
institutions were falling over
themselves to go after Trump and we'll
do everything their power to defend Joe
Biden yeah I mean at what point in in
American history has a group of 700
former commissioned officers and
intelligence operators signed a letter
saying get this guy out of office who by
the way had us in the best trade
position with China we've been in since
we started trade with China and get in
this bumbling buffoon that we have in
now who has these weird ties through his
family to China One of the leaders of
that movement was J again James Mattis
and almost after he resigned he he got
brought on as a partner at the Cohen
group The Cohen group William Cohen
another former Secretary of Defense they
have four offices two of them are in
China and one of the things that they do
the Cohen group is negotiate deals
between American and Chinese companies
that's what they specialize in right so
you have maybe the most popular
Secretary of Defense ever until his
little you know that that whole
resignation thing a guy with immense
power a guy who's now hooked up with
four other former secretaries of defense
so you have the defense industry both on
the private and public side right and
you have a compromised presidency that
completely botches the situation in
Afghanistan that turns over the largest
amount of wealth ever given from one
entity to another ever I mean Trump was
the one who's trying to pull us out of
Afghanistan sure and we should have
pulled out of Afghanistan I mean but the
issue is if there's a better spot for us
it's easier it's easier there's more
there's more lithium in Peru and Chile
by a wide margin Alaska as well but if
we wanted a partner country right where
we could pay lower wages to get it mined
but those wages still mean something to
those people that's a good deal the
point is if
Afghanistan's national government stood
it would have been much more difficult
for China and a couple weeks before the
fall of Kabul the president called Joe
Biden and said we need air support and
Biden said just a lie say everything's
going well so they knew how bad it was
they had evacuated Bagram in the middle
of the night without telling the Afghan
Army without telling the government now
that sounds like sabotage to me but it
certainly does yeah but we do got to go
to super chats so if you haven't already
smash that like button subscribe to the
channel share the show with your friends
and go to timcast.com become a member
support our work and you'll get access
to our exclusive members on these
segments we got a big update we got a
couple new members only shows that are
gonna be coming up one's called The
Green Room where in the in the early
minutes when guests arrive and there's
Shenanigans going on and off the cuff
conversations we're actually going to
put that up as members only content so
as soon as the show ends you'll get that
and then we'll have the full member
segment coming up right afterwards so
just more and more stuff for you guys
and um that's in development right now
and it should be should be relatively
soon and it'll be a lot of fun One
You're Gonna the point of that show is
basically you'll have someone say you
know Alex Jones shows up instead of
talking politics someone might be
talking about him talking to him about
his brownie recipe or like his aunt's
famous apple pie just like random
Welcome to The Green Room here's the
house so it's kind of vloggy but you
know it's interesting conversations we
had uh um Andreas who who's a part of
the Vlog talking to Steve Bannon about
like Quantum communism and technocracy
and just Bannon was like this guy's a
genius yeah he's crazy though but yeah
smart guy and so it's funny stuff so
definitely stay tuned for that be a
member and I also have news we are
um tired of waiting to put on the Live
Events we've had an issue there's just
red tape it's the government stuff
running a business and we've been like
we got to do this but we're going to Pro
there's a local venue and I say local
it's a big area so it's still a little
far away but we're going to be putting
an event the the capacity is probably
it's like between 200 and 400 I'm not
entirely sure and uh again we're gonna
we're gonna make the announcement on the
official date with RSVP
um four members who give 25 bucks or
more then the next day they'll go to all
members and the next day it'll go to
everyone and for now we're planning on
being a totally free event just it's
going to be RSVP first because of
limited capacity and then we're going to
notify People based on you know one of
the things we plan to do is that if
you're a member at 25 or more you get
advanced notice for our events so we'll
try and stay true to that we're going to
stay true to that and then um there'll
be live music we have I believe we're
confirmed on our stand-up comedy
headliner and opening act which you guys
are going to be super excited for when
we're ready to announce it we need to
confirm the date with the venue then
we'll announce the idea for the show
um then we'll set up RSVP and do it in a
staggered Manner and we got to figure
out whether or not we're going to
announce the venue at the very last
minute and that may be the case for
obvious reasons but you know just stay
tuned because it'll be coming soon I'm
hoping the next few days to actually
confirm with the venue on the dates have
everything locked in and then we can put
it up on the site for RSVP so stay tuned
let's read some super chats
let's see crust what does it say crustum
Fab crust crust turn custom small screen
I am a huge Dan Holloway fan I also just
got back from voting this isn't over
till it's over tomorrow is the last day
go vote in that recall election
all right let's see
Bradley tunesi says
hey Dan and Tim love the show guys my
question is I hear that there will be a
time to stand to tyranny all the time
but when I but when and how do we go
about that love the American party give
a kiss to the doctor
so here's what I've been saying
that's Dakota Meyer by the way Medal of
Honor recipient he's been
pretending to be a doctor he got an
honorary doctorate from some school I've
never heard of and he once shut his
mouth about it and to be honest I may
have to enter him at some point but
anyways that's a good question people
ask me that a lot well we're in
fourth and fifth generational warfares
we've been describing it and that's a
cold war right I mean it's it's
different no it's not cold well in in
the way that uh in the way that we would
think about the cold war that we refer
to we are in a cold war but that wasn't
a cold war either right it never was so
like how many conflicts we had Korea was
a major one but we had micro conflicts
all over the world for 45 50 years
exactly and so that's exactly what's
happening now it's the Next Generation
so you've got fights happening in the
streets people being shot
that stuff's been happening for years
and it seems to be spiking up and
disappearing and there's some events
worse than others
I just say
you've got to win hearts and minds and
you got to be very strategic about how
you do it violence does not win hearts
and Minds now the mainstream media has
defended antifung covered up for them
recently there was a story in the
post-millennial about a far-left
terrorist trying to uh I forgot what's
called shunting a train track to derail
the trains and cause crashes and
convicted so look these people are still
like it's possible that they get
convicted they get arrested there's a
lot of people you've got to be
persuasive and you've got to build
public support and then when the culture
shifts the courts follow you think
appointing judge is going to save you
nope the judges will just do what they
think is popular with the mainstream for
the most part so be persuasive be
resourceful be peaceful I think we're in
a cultural Insurgency right now so the
if you look at the stages of Insurgency
the first thing you do is gain awareness
right well you you form your Insurgency
then you gain awareness like hey here we
are and it's like that uh if you've ever
read the marketing book traction it
almost follows the same pathway of a
startup company so you gain uh awareness
first then second thing you do is gain
patronage this is where
um the I feel like the Occupy Movement
got got it right for a little while and
then fell off uh because you can't gain
patronage through violence and you can't
gain patronage by standing in the middle
of the road people that want to support
you now will not because you right
you've done stupid thing if you were
doing something that they thought was
important and an inconvenience them they
would probably join you to be honest but
they would at least understand if you do
something that's completely irrelevant
to the problem blocking traffic and
sleeping Outdoors is not protesting
that's not what it is people like to
talk about Martin Luther King Jr and
Malcolm X and Martin Luther King Jr
peaceful persuasive resourceful even at
a time of escalated violence and we then
years later you get the weather
underground and this guy is an American
hero an American icon so you got to be
smart about how you do it times are
changing you know uh here we go we got
pad Dash hey Tim I loved watching your
latest cast Castle Vlog and your
reaction to the custom desk mat I made
for you it was priceless if you want to
make a rainbow don't tread on me desk
mat for your new studio you know where
uh to make it keep up the good work
thank you very much pad Dash we got this
uh it was the it was the uh chicken
dance a chicken party with Tim Poole
anime opening for our Vlog which is a
bunch of art I know it was really really
cool and uh yeah man absolutely uh thank
you very much I love the rainbow don't
tread on me flag because it's the
ultimate like I'm gonna do what I want
so I think that's really funny plus it
it's funny because there's a there's a a
news article where it showed a guy in
Santa Monica protesting mandates and he
was holding a rainbow Gadsden flag and
I'm like I think people who are into
don't tread on me are gonna be like
right on like because it doesn't matter
what color the flag is as long as you're
saying leave me alone and I'll leave you
alone but boy the left did not like it
right like why is that white supremacy
on our oh yeah that's oh man good Lord
whatever all right Turk Longwell says
Tim now we know the secret to your
success not hard work experience or
occupy it was Small Town casino slots
and gambling shout out to the cast team
uh so if those aren't familiar hey if
it's dumb and it works is it really dumb
so uh I'm really good at gambling for
some reason and uh we went to these hot
spots in West Virginia all over the
place where you could just like bars
have slot machines oh yeah and I won two
jackpots I went in with 60 bucks walked
out with four how can you can't say
you're good at that that's kind of
coincidence right nope I was gonna say
that one but now I'm thinking of like
the magnetic fields and they're running
through you so you might be connected to
some no no you're you're you're you're
you're uh
you're missing it and you're
overthinking it again
these games are all programmed
programming can't be random
it's that simple
so if someone is trying to determine a
specific outcome in that this machine
must pay out 98 of all money it takes in
meaning for every dollar that comes in
98 cents goes out these hot spots and
casinos know for a fact that slots can't
pay out more than they take in that
means someone programmed them that means
that program you can understand how
these slots whether you can program a
random number generator uh you can do it
using static but these have to have a
predetermined outcome which means they
can't right right they have to pay out
less than they make yes which means it
can't be random it has to be algorithmic
and if that's the case
it's actually quite simple most slot
machines operate on very very similar
algorithms because they have controlled
payout and if you know how to do that
you end up with Vlogs back to back where
I win four jackpots in 20 minutes in two
days we have X-ray vision you see that
they're filled and you know that they're
going to start paying out it's you know
people think counting cards is a really
complicated process and it's
ridiculously simple literally simple
you're like a face card one you know not
a face card I'll do nothing it's like
just Google it oh that's easy it's super
easy and then when the count is high it
changes your strategy they know when
you're doing it though so in like Vegas
they get mad about it I think in
Atlantic City you're allowed to do it
and all it does is it increases your
odds to slightly above uh 50 so you're
you're working but you might be making I
think they say like 20 to 50 bucks an
hour I mean look professional
professional sports gamblers and these
are people not in uh decks of cards or
on roulette tables or in places where
they're a lot more I mean look there's a
lot of variables in sports gambling but
if you look at the way Vegas handicaps
they are within one point or so know of
their of their spread almost always
right but professional gamblers still
only win about 55 to 58 of their bets
and that's enough yeah it's enough so
good enough yeah yeah so so anyway there
was a story I saw a long time ago about
a guy who solved um lottery tickets
scratchers because a lot of the
scratchers would have numbers on the
front that you'd scratch off and reveal
a symbol and he said if the if the
outcome needs to be controlled it cannot
be random right in which case you can
figure out the algorithm and know which
number correlates with which symbol he
solved it he then started looking at
lottery tickets and he could pick the
winners and losers oh my God and then he
he filled an envelope with two envelopes
one said winners one said losers he was
trying to tell the lottery Commissions
in Canada and they were ignoring him
because he's a crackpot with a
conspiracy finally they opened it up and
found out he was right the same is true
for slot machines they are programs they
are games you I I it's it's I'll tell
you this it is ridiculously easy to
guarantee a jackpot on a slot machine
how I mean are you have a secret you
don't want to give away I don't advise
giving away your secret I'm gonna give
it away yeah yeah that's cool but I'll
tell you this
um we didn't oh man I think it's I I uh
we didn't even mention this because it's
not in the in the Vlog but when we were
in West Virginia Central West Virginia
I won three jackpots in one night uh and
jackpot's there a couple hundred bucks
right then we went to the casino on
Sunday was it Sunday or was it Saturday
I think it was Saturday and I won a
jackpot they actually gave me a tax form
I have to pay taxes on the winning so
like when I won the jackpot they're like
okay gotta fill this out and then just
the other day we went to a pool hall
where that I won two more jackpots I
have the videos on my phone I could I'll
put it up on Instagram and I'm not
kidding one two more jackpots I know
exactly how these things work so um you
gotta look deep you got to understand
how the system works how like like I
said one of the only ways to get true
random is through like background static
it's not super easy to do yeah we should
read super jets but now everyone's like
how does he do it yeah I'm thinking if
it's like you look the way it's like
they spawn and the way they've landed
you can see that they've spun x amount
of things you're overthinking it yeah
you're overthinking that's how I work
yeah so in in this in the span of uh man
it was yeah it was last Sunday
wow it was last Sunday I went to the hot
spot and won three three jackpots then
it was one week not less than a week
later I won another jackpot on a bigger
machine and then it was
Sunday I won two more so like within
seven days I won what is that seven
jackpots well I am pumped to find out I
filmed all of it too we didn't put all
of the jackpots in the in the in the
Vlog too many jackpots but I've got I've
got two more I can put up on Instagram
and show you
all right let's see actually I think I
got three I don't know I lost track
all right all right Bourne Stellar says
buddy you are completely wrong I'm a
marine eighty percent of us would never
shoot an American
sure you're incorrect
I only got one word to say to prove that
wrong
antifa
if you saw a group of antifa armed with
handguns and ARs and they were running
through the streets and firing
yeah a lot of people cop would shoot him
so what are you saying you're seeing if
you oppose them ideologically then you
would shoot them
I'm saying not necessarily that I'm
saying if you were deployed you know for
whatever reason or uh some like you're
on a military base and then some chaos
happens and then so it's not that it's a
violation of Posse commentatives or
anything like that right but if you saw
a group
that it doesn't matter who they were and
they were armed and they were engaging
in combat you'd probably neutralize them
I mean yeah I would do that right now as
a civilian though exactly that's not
well so here's the here's it's different
when you're uh like you said with
positive obviously but just generally
speaking there's a different weight to
that decision when you're wearing
uniforms what is uh it means that uh you
can't use military as police basically
uh they can't enforce domestic laws
unless only I think only in extreme
circumstances maybe put under the
authority of a local police station uh
um I don't technically not I don't think
local police stations but federal law
enforcement yes I think if there's what
the sicario movie is about it's I think
with the Insurrection act they can you
need the answers
uh what I'm saying is the question is
people assume when a Commanding Officer
says shoot that American they'd be like
looking at this like granny waving a
trump flag yeah it's not going to be
like that it's going to be a dude in a
vest and he's gonna have he's gonna have
a weapon well here you are though we're
having that conversation we were talking
about earlier where we're talking about
two different definitions of of things
right so this this Marine is probably
talking about I'm not going to March
into a U.S city and start rounding
people up and he's right they wouldn't
do that I I sincerely believe they
wouldn't I know these people and I've
been in that position there's no way but
in a small on conflict I disagree and a
smaller Conflict for sure if I think the
police would be more likely to do that
than military people in order for the
military to ever get involved in any
kind of conflict like that it would have
to have gotten so bad where it's like
there's bombings and cities are you know
script to the point where they're like
Insurrection act has been declared and
then the military is going to be told
look we've got Insurgent extremists
they're armed with pipe bombs explosives
we don't want to shoot them but you need
to protect yourself first and foremost
when you when you're given that
intelligence do you question your
commanding officer do you say you're
wrong you're lying no you trust them no
no no no you don't trust your absolutely
not I know like I mean I mean I I was
taught and I taught my people to never
just trust anything like that at face
value the more extreme it's what's
what's uh
um
I can't remember how the phrase goes but
it's something if if you're asserting
something that's uh uh the stronger your
assertion is the stronger your evidence
must be right something to that effect
and that is absolutely the case well now
that's not the case for everyone
obviously right so my my question to
that is why did a bunch of why did a
family get drones get hit by a drone
strike in Afghanistan because that drone
strike happened uh from a an Air Force
Base called Creech just north of Las
Vegas right in North Las Vegas actually
it happened 8 000 miles away from that
location and to the operator the Drone
operator that's just a a little it's
it's tops of heads that's that's why so
the issue I suppose is what you see what
what's the what's that movie or it's a
TV series
um I think it's the second season of uh
Jack Ryan if I'm not mistaken or maybe
it's the first season of Jack Ryan the
new series that was on Amazon Prime the
dude from the office yeah where the the
Drone operator
uh kills the wrong person or something
like that or they get they had bad Intel
then it's part of the the story
um I I would imagine that that's that's
probably a difficult thing to do I don't
know if I could be a drone operator oh
that'd be so hard it's a lot easier to
walk up to somebody see that they're a
threat and then put a bullet in their
brain than it is to drop a bomb on
somebody and not know by the time the
bomb hits the ground are they going to
be standing there is it somebody's kid
like that Anwar I'll lock you the first
time we tried to kill him we killed a
kid right no no that was we were going
after he was already dead uh abduraman
was killed after I'm pretty sure after
Anwar and he was in Yemen anwar's child
the first time we tried to kill him well
I don't know maybe it wasn't his child
but children died the first time duraman
was killed I think after the fact and
Obama claimed that they were trying to
Target a different you know Al Qaeda
terrorist and it was an accident they
blew up a civilian restaurant
yeah it was it was somebody's wedding I
believe the first strike right oh the
first track right yeah yeah yeah I
wonder if it's like if we didn't have
this uh Patriot Act thing where we can
say anyone's a terrorist at any time and
then we can drone strike him any time
that we that the government or the
people in power feel like they wouldn't
have enough power if they didn't have
that ability that they would be
destroyed well let's let's let's let's
agree to disagree for the most part but
I would say I think if there was a group
of antifa Flying antifa Flags and they
were armed and they were shooting I
would I mean a lot of people would shoot
them to be honest right now I would do
that so like if they were shooting at
people you'd stop them yeah if I saw
anybody conducting a shooting like that
and they weren't clearly uniformed which
is to say I know that they're doing that
on for some reason that would make me
hesitate and ask why they're doing it
but if if I just saw that happening I
would smoke that person so I think I
think it's fair to say like when someone
just abruptly is like I would never
shoot an American it's like no yeah you
would right Americans get shot by other
Americans all the time right right all
right the one free man says read
ordinary men a book of how a book of how
normal men become cold-blooded murderers
in Poland during World War II don't
think you would never do horrible things
instead think what it would take for you
to do horrible things uh one-third were
Nazi informants in World War II wow
interesting yeah you know a lot of
people are like you know like at what
point is do I stand up to tyranny and
it's like honestly I think you're you're
peaceful obviously there's a threshold
right if we got to the point of actual
death camps and like you know gestapo
type police then you're in a children's
Hot War at that point right exactly
exactly everybody knows what the rules
are but like with the it's I've actually
found it pretty interesting to hear the
whole ritten house debate play out over
the last two years or so because people
even on the right have different
opinions about stuff
um the left obviously outright condemns
it because they disagree with him
politically I guess I don't know I don't
know what their basis is I mean
apparently getting uh despite what the
law says about having a blunt object
swung at your head and your ability to
defend yourself when that happens or
somebody trying to shoot you with a
Glock uh but maybe the circumstance that
brought him there I think he's a really
interesting case because this is a kid
who is by and large there to do the
right thing he was trying to clean up
put out fires he was there to do the
right thing and then stuff went a little
wild maybe he was a little out of his
depth but I don't think anything it's
it's a it is very upsetting to me that
he got charged with murder in the first
place and if he gets convicted of this
that would that would be one of the
biggest miscarriages of Justice I think
in modern history I think it'll happen
oh definitely there's a lot of activists
in the DA's these days that's a problem
well it's not that I mean when when
chauvin's trial can be surrounded by
fences and men with machine guns because
there's active riding in the city and
then they're like we will not change
location and he didn't get a mistrial
for that right how do you if if that's
not a mistrial then one doesn't exist
and so it was a really great point I
think it was Will Chamberlain said this
and if it wasn't I forgive whoever did
that when the judge said everyone in the
state knows what happened who this guy
is so there's no other venue in which we
could have a more fair trial at that
point you say charges dropped have a
nice day if you cannot have a fair trial
you you're free to go right I mean the
other way around what are the chances
that Rittenhouse is going to get
anything approaching a fair trial
despite the fact that a pedophile armed
with a weapon he wasn't supposed to have
tried to shoot him and that guy no that
guy tried taking his gun from him well
one guy had a Glock right oh that was
the guy yeah guy who the guy so okay the
first guy was the pedophile then
Rittenhouse was being chased by the pedo
guy yeah and then some other guy fired
at Rittenhouse who then heard the shot
turned around and when he did I think
guy's name was Rosenbaum reached for the
gun and missed and then Kyle fired and
fired and fired okay well look if I'm
carrying a weapon and you are a much
larger person there have been there's
case law on this with women by the way
no but I was smaller than him where uh
well it doesn't matter he's an adult he
was a 17 year old kid yeah so there
there's a case log that's where women
have pulled out weapons to defend
themselves the man try to take it away
and he was unarmed she shot him
perfectly fine to do that by the way if
you're it's political the the
presumption is if I have a weapon and
you're trying to take it from me you're
going to take it from me and use it on
me right yeah you're not taking
anonymity to the disarming then go home
after you've been violently chasing me
down the street so he was right to shoot
that guy was right to shoot but and then
he was chased and he was trying to get
to the cops and the guy was trying to
hit him with a with a skateboard in the
back of the head he shot that guy and
then the other guy got his bicycle well
no no the the so what happened was he
got shoved to the ground right and then
they got the skateboard tried grabbing
the gun and when he reached for the gun
and missed Rittenhouse fired up and went
into his heart the other guy then
approached with his Glock right and went
to grab the gun and then writtenhouse
pointed at him the guy backed up and put
his hands up and then he lunged again
and Rittenhouse shot him and blew off
his bicep so it sounds like the kid's a
lot better
at fighting than these other terms and
that guy with the gun later said uh it's
been a long time since we reported this
so fact check me this one I may be wrong
but the bicep guy you mean the bicep guy
I'm pretty sure he said I should have
just you know yeah
that yeah I should have just what why
I'm paraphrasing but he was like I
should have just unloaded into one of
them yeah oh wow yeah wow I mean look if
you're on if you're on your heels well I
mean he's literally on his back firing
the weapon at that point you have no
right to walk up and just start shooting
the kid am I am I off on that
like I I feel like the the how he was
there in the first place there might be
some questions about for his mother like
why is your 17th that's that's a
personal in the middle yeah exactly that
has nothing to do with me and you can't
just because somebody ended up in a
situation because of whatever all that's
in the past who cares what happened once
people started taking responsibility for
their own actions right you saw what
happened like these these are criminals
the guy one guy was a pedophile the
other guy that had the Glock was a felon
he shouldn't have had the gun in the
first place right so what are we talking
about here I never understood why there
was such a debate over this he's
becoming Effigy for this place if uh
I've made some crazy bets I've dropped a
bunch of money down on on roulette wheel
to see what would happen and uh
sometimes I lose sometimes you win you
know I've put a bunch of crazy money in
slot machines and tend to win if I had
to make a bet right now I'm not saying
it's a guaranteed Victory like I'd put a
hundred bucks down and win 100 bucks
like I did it I'd be willing to bet
that uh uh he gets life I think I would
if I was like on a roulette wheel and I
was trying to figure out like what's a
good odds for winning I'd be like oh
yeah yeah life in prison what if you
didn't have to make a bet
on this what do you mean you said if I
have to make a bet I would bet that life
in prison but if I didn't have to make a
point would you make a 60 chance he gets
a life so if you had to make a bet would
you or if you didn't have to make a bet
would you is my point like yes that's my
point you think it's actually that that
good of odds that you would risk yes on
wow I don't know that's my point I don't
know because I agree this is like bro
they had machines and barricades outside
of the Chauvin trial and they had rivals
in the city and the jurors said I was
scared of retaliation it was like it was
like a hockey game they're like banging
on the glass like oh are you kidding me
how is that but what two or three hours
of Kenosha are gonna cry and beg antifa
to spare that oh yeah two or three
months before that they'll uh a federal
courthouse is getting attacked a police
station gets burned to the ground and
what happens nothing literally antifa
set up an autonomous Zone they took over
by force an area of a major U.S city for
a month
and how many people have been arrested
because of that I don't know I mean
Nadler refused to admit that antifa even
existed are you kidding me yeah
how do you fight an enemy that no one
will agree even exist that's that's
something that we're going to happen I
don't think anyone in politics mentioned
antifa until that political debate with
Donald Trump Joe Biden yeah yep yeah I
mean that's one thing uh Trump
definitely always got right he never let
anybody slip by like if there was
something to be said if there was an
elephant in the room he was like Hey
elephant elephant okay Trump did talk
about it yeah yeah
all right let's see
people are talking about rabies vaccines
oh yeah Rose M says nah bro I've had the
rabies vaccine series it's only three
shots over about a month not bad they
hurt less than flu shots what if that's
like an updated update I'm pretty sure
it is yeah I'm pretty sure it used to be
way worse than they've been improving on
it yeah yes
smart audience the licensed Guru says
love how happy Ian is today good vibes
from everyone all right I've actually I
watched some of the the live chat going
through it's funny how much people roast
you it's awesome it's it's really I love
I really enjoy when people uh do that if
I I it upsets me sometimes when my
friends get attacked I don't know what
that is about me but uh when people come
after me as long as it's funny
yeah that makes my sometimes I'll just
sit there you remember the Mean Tweets
thing that used to be a thing on late
night television yeah where people had
fun reading Mean Tweets about themselves
now you get banned I have so much love
for you typing these things thank you
the tactician musician says nothing
irritates me more than the president of
the US saying it's not about Freedom
it's about safety America is freedom how
many people risk life for freedom in the
wars how many people are risking life
right now traveling through Mexico and
how many people list how many people are
taking risks by just like walking
through the forest when there could be a
big cat or a bear or something you
choose to take those risks that's on you
all right
um burad is challenging me and I think I
might fail
dude she sells seashells by the seashore
toy boat toy boat toy boat toy boat
nailed it nice work
you practiced that when you were a kid
some Wingnut says what are your feelings
on Joe Rogan being able to perform in
New York City without being vaxxed uh is
Joe he's doing the Madison Square Garden
really so he's he's he's gonna
I guess he's certainly not vaccinated
um I don't know if he's ever said
whether he was or wasn't it was reported
that he wasn't he's he said that he
wasn't oh really I think so uh but so
not only Madison Square Garden has its
own rule about vaccination but now New
York City has gone into effect as well
right so but he's uh performers are
Exempted I mean it was like uh Chappelle
used to talk about that a lot with the
cigarette thing he could smoke on stage
but you couldn't it was it was a part of
his performance I gotta say if uh maybe
we should this all become stand-up
comedians well this is this is this is a
big one if uh I know Joe I I talked to
Joe every so often I have mad respect
for the guy but I do have to point this
out if Joe was going to go on his show
and you know be critical of vaccines uh
to whatever extent and he's going to
um you know be talking with like Brett
Weinstein and talking about these things
if he's going to oppose mandatory
vaccinations but then
create a circumstance as a performer in
New York which would result in thousands
of people who want to see him getting
vaccinated or at least upholding the
mandate system right I gotta say that's
that's a
I don't know is that hypocritical he's
yeah a little bit he's I think he's got
to criticize it and maybe I bet if you
put it to him that way he would probably
agree with it though to be honest he
probably just hasn't considered that yet
because there is some responsibility
when you get uh when you have an
audience and wait like that he's gonna
he will make Madison Square Garden
probably three to five million dollars
just in ticket sales at night and then
you can add about one multiply that
times 1.6 or so for all the concessions
it's basically standing in line to
defend the vaccine mandate essentially
yeah but the so I've had a number of
friends who are performers uh of varying
degrees of celebrity say I'm not going
to perform there because they have a
vaccine mandate I don't know I'm not
going to subject my fans of that but
I've seen uh people none that I know but
people on the other side do the same
thing say I'm not going to a place that
doesn't require vaccination right you
know this challenge is a lot of money
you know but I guess I would look at it
this way
what does Joe do with his money in a way
that benefits freedom and challenges the
things that he opposes honestly I don't
know I mean he probably starting a
comedy club I know that maybe he donates
I'm you know I'm not trying to accuse
him of not doing or doing anything I'm
just saying here's the factors
if they pay if he gets if he ends up
getting paid millions of dollars and
then he says I'm gonna take this money
and I'm gonna put it into legal work to
sue the hell out of New York City to end
this I'd be like dude it would be taking
the money from the system to throw it
back in their faces if he just says well
you know what people can do whatever
they want I think vaccine mandates are
bad but if they want to get vaccinated
it's on them I'll do the show then
you're propping up the system you claim
to oppose
so I guess the ultimate issue is uh here
I don't know if he's doing the show I
don't know what's going on with it I
don't know yeah they're selling tickets
October 2nd 2021 Madison Square Garden
if you go to the Ticketmaster page it
pops up a covid health check required in
order to attend the event all guests age
12 and older must provide proof of
school speaking of that when is is there
if it were me I would say event canceled
yeah or I'd move that's what Jim
Brewer's doing yeah I'd move it I just
moved it they were canceled I wonder if
there's going to be anybody uh what
when's the First Federal lawsuit going
to come in the form of the same one from
the George Mason University Professor
that said that his natural immunity
should take the place of a vaccine right
what if he he won that case in federal
court by the way what if your doctor
says you can't get the vaccine right and
that New York says there's no exemption
too bad if if your doctor says you can't
get the vaccine then they can't not
exempt you because the Ada prevents them
from doing that but they're doing it
anyway right I called 25 restaurants I'm
sure so I mean that's that kind of uh
begs the question why do why do we have
gun laws if they don't actually if if
words on paper don't actually stop
anything if it doesn't stop the
government from telling me what I can
and can't do where I can and can't go
then what is the point of any of that
stuff exactly so many people are feeling
that right now what is the point but
that's a good thing though I think it's
a good thing for people to
realize that the system they're in isn't
what they thought it was that these
words on paper mean nothing I Phil
Jackson used to say that you're only a
success in the moment that you perform a
successful act that's a very very good
quote and I would I would add to that
you're only kind in the moment that you
perform a kind act you're only a patriot
in the in the moment you perform a
patriotic act because it puts the owners
back on you to not just say things not
just read words on paper but to live
that life you know I think it was
Breitbart who said politics is
Downstream from culture yep I think
there's a better way to say it politics
is a relevant to fight for culture
because in New York City you have uh I
called one of the restaurants you know I
called a bunch of the restaurants and
one of them I asked him you know would
you you know hey we you know if I came
in would you deny my friend access
because they can't get the vaccine the
doctor won't let him right and they said
yes they can't come in and then I said
you though you can eat outside on
Michael we don't want to eat outside
that's like segregation it's like
discriminatory like the doctor's not
allowing my friend to get the vaccine
and they said I'm sorry that's those are
the rules we're just following with the
you know the mayor's orders and then I
said well this violates the Americans
with Disabilities Act and New York City
human rights law about discriminating
based on the basis of medical conditions
right and then someone else picked up
the phone and went by and then he was
like it's project Veritas hang it up
yeah well so so so
you know that's why I say like people
seem to think that they're so oh I would
always stand up and I would dude the
people of New York City have buckled in
two seconds and all of your precious
laws you've got New York City you've got
New York state and federal
anti-discrimination laws gone why
because the fascists of New York are
willing to drop to their need to gag on
boot the moment de Blasio says so and so
long as the people are going to grovel
before de Blasio your paper means
nothing you'll stand there being like
but I have a constitution saying and
he's going to be like look at all of my
subjects around me you could totally and
then he'll say subjects rise beat him
and they'll say Yes master that's good
that Constitution is only as strong as
the Fist and gun behind it right yeah
that's why the Second Amendment exists
this it wasn't to protect us from a
foreign army does do people still
believe that nonsense
it partially I mean I think it was uh so
the reason they the original second
amendment was actually I think it was
the fourth and it was long right and it
said regardless of whether or not you're
in it had a provision that said
regardless of military service you are
entitled to keep and bear arms they
removed it because they were worried it
would be used as an argument to stop
conscription right so actually yeah the
purpose of the second amendment was
foreign and domestic that internally
terrorism tyranny or externally War an
armed population keeps it safe this
covet could be the shock to the system
that inoculates us against this stupid
creep of totalitarianism because our
rights are not set in stone they only
exist when we enforce them by enacting
them look at Australia bro look at it
that could be us and it's not right now
and it won't be if we choose it not to
be well we're heading that direction
well I that's a dangerous thing to say
because you can't speak for everyone
like that we will see how it goes but
we're going to have a members only
segment coming up on a timcast.com so
become a member go to teamcaster crimes
timcast.com com subscribe make sure you
like the video right now like this
podcast share it with your friends
subscribe to this Channel and you can
follow us at timcastirl basically
everywhere or somewhere some places like
Tim cast underscore IRL you can follow
me personally and watch me engage in
Shenanigans at timcast and I'll post
those videos of me winning the jackpots
to back up my claims that yes I win them
all the time uh at timcast on Instagram
and other places I want to find out
where you're doing it and I'm gonna just
wait outside and Rob you every time you
win the jackpot I mean it's a couple
hundred bucks like you're going to the
hot spot tonight you're my hot spot I'm
just gonna follow you around and Rob you
every time I need a different series of
masks maybe you can help me with that
definitely
in West Virginia I ain't worried about
it that's constitutional yeah well Texas
just passed that too yes right you can
walk around West Virginia with like a
Barrett M82 I don't know why you'd want
to it's very heavy yeah absolutely yeah
it's bulky do you want to shout anything
out uh yeah you can just follow me on
Instagram at uh Dan Holloway I do a lot
of weird stuff over there gets a lot of
a lot of my posts get deleted for
various reasons right on thanks for
coming everyone great to see you man
yeah awesome thanks guys good to see you
again Ian Crossland fall
mediancrosslin.net or anywhere at Ian
Crossland uh exists
and I was gonna say I'm surprised Dan
didn't shout out his podcast which is
drinking bro well it's on my hat okay
yeah yeah okay yeah so that's that's a
podcast I've been listening to it I've
been really enjoying it I've been
talking about Afghanistan I also want to
shout out shout out the quartering he's
in here do you know the guy no of course
yeah I like he's he's uh he gave me he's
hanging out he gave me some heat uh one
time for some stupid things I said and
they were definitely stupid we can get
to that on the uh members only part yeah
Jeremy's cool dude as we were sitting
here I was like I feel like you have the
Cadence of Jeremy it went through my
head a couple times during the show we
both have beards um yeah it like weighs
your face down a certain amount I don't
know right on yeah and you guys should
follow me on Twitter at Sour Patch Lids
because I want more followers than Sour
Patch Kids that's all I want that's all
I want we will see you all at
timcast.com for the member segment
thanks very much bye guys